this is Jocko podcast number 163 echo
Charles and me Jacque are willing
good evening echo good evening I am
bleeding out I can feel my life ebbing
away as blood seeps from my body into
the Iraqi soil a few Brown weeds
splashed crimson now are crushed around
me as I lay sprawled on my back in the
middle of this ambush the weeds offer no
concealment I'm in the open alone and
wounded sizzles of pain hid me in waves
like pulses of electricity a bullet has
torn off my left arm after I get hit I
reach over to grab my left hand it isn't
there I hunt around feeling only the
gear on the far left side of my body no
arm I try to move the fingers on my left
hand but my mind sends signals to a
station that doesn't exist now I can't
feel anything but pain bullets kick dirt
in my face through my night-vision
goggles I see green blooms of light
strobing the darkness muzzle flashes
from automatic weapons ten metres away
an enemy machine-gun opens fire again it
is a belt-fed russian-made crew-served
weapon probably a PKM they sound like
giant zippers tearing open when the
Gunners go cyclic like now the air
around me erupts with sharp cracks the
miniature sonic booms of 760 millimeter
bullets speeding past me at 2500 feet
per second the terrorist gunner lowers
his aim a spurt of dust blows across my
face again several bullets passed so
close to my head that I feel shockwaves
as they go by
to the left an ak-47 assault rifle opens
up then another I'm pinned in a
crossfire without cover or concealment a
crippled sitting duck in a kill zone at
least a hundred metres long and 75 deep
with my right hand I key the radio
handset I have mounted on my chest
troops in contact troops in contact
I call to my command we have three
severely wounded including me
static greets my words
I can't duck
I can't crawl away there's no place to
hide all I can do is ignore the incoming
fire and stay focused the PKM gun PKM
gunner finds the range bullets crack
around me dirt flies the terrorist eases
up on the trigger trigger but only for a
second
I hear him unleash another burst then I
hear nothing at all
and those right there are some excerpts
from the opening chapter of a book
called the Trident which is written by a
retired seal officer by the name of
Jason J Redman and this book does an
incredible job not only of bringing the
reader to the front lines in some pretty
chaotic combat situations but equally
important it brings the reader into the
challenges of leadership and the
challenges of life especially the
challenges of facing significant
adversity and Jay's book humbly splays
those challenges wide open for all to
see and that humility from Jay is what
makes this book so beneficial he tells
us plainly and bluntly of his personal
triumphs and tragedies his victories and
his defeats and how he eventually found
success and overcame by traveling the
path of humility and since I have the
honor of actually knowing Jay he has
been kind enough to come by this evening
and talk about his experiences with us
so with that mr. Jay Redman
thanks for stopping by brother Jocko
brother echo thank you thank you both
for having me on
awesome dude awesome to have you sitting
here man hey man honored to still be
here
blessed that's for sure you know like I
tell so many people I'm living on a
second chance you know you and I got too
many brothers who are not I don't know
why the big man decided to give me a
chance but I'm making the most of it
outstanding so I want to try and start
you know a little bit at the beginnings
people get a little bit familiar with
where you are everyone always wants to
know where people are where people came
from how they grew up I'm going to the
book right here I came from a family
with a rich tradition of service so in
retrospect this made sense
my dad was a US Army Airborne rigger at
Fort Campbell during the Vietnam War my
paternal grandfather earned a
Distinguished Flying Cross while
piloting a b-24 Liberator bomber over
the flak filled skies of Hitler's Europe
I also had a great-uncle who flew
fighter aircraft in the southwest
Pacific during World War two he made the
ultimate sacrifice in battle against the
Japanese I dreamed of adding to that
legacy a life of combat medals and
service I was young and naive and had a
long road to travel before I could truly
understand what my grandfather and
great-uncle gave for the country but
that idealism became a very big part of
me I wanted to carry a rifle for a
living my dad watched this desire grow
in me and decided to focus it my
freshman year in high school he sat me
down in our tiny living room and said
you know Jay we had these guys come
through airborne school they were US
Navy called seals they jumped out of
airplanes swam they blues blue stuff up
given how you loved the water maybe you
ought to look into them so your dad
planted the seed huh it did yeah a young
age and you know this was 90 play I'm
sorry
probably 89 you know 88 89
back then you really couldn't find
hardly anything about the SEAL Teams and
this was at a point in time where GI Joe
was big I mean I'm a you know 12 13 year
old kid into that and then I was
probably about 14 when my dad told me
about the SEAL Teams and started
researching it found almost nothing and
by sheer happenstance one of the guys in
our church was a huge special operations
buff he was a guy that was unable to go
in the military he had had polio
actually when he was a kid but he was
just infatuated by it and he had done
tons of research and he actually had
collected some things about the SEAL
Teams he had an old soldier of Fortune
magazine and yeah it was awesome it's so
different nowadays no now did you just
google it exactly back in the day you
had to be lucky enough to know some dude
in church who happen to have a copy of
the issue of soldier of fortune magazine
is that still a thing his fortune still
out there that dude it actually is as a
matter of fact somehow and some weird
twist of fate I ended up being on the
cover of soldier of fortune after the
book came out and it was the most
bizarre thing because now you know
you're in the military and you look at
this thing you kind of laugh it's a
fortune it's a little bit of a you know
really focuses on probably the the
gung-ho aspect of soft as opposed to you
came full circle yeah
full circle that's for sure build a
soldier of fortune it was it was pretty
funny but but that magazine and that
journey of coming to understand who
these guys were they you really couldn't
find much about them it just drew me in
even more and the only thing the core
thread that I found over and over again
was toughest training in the military
and you know I was a young kid I was a
small kid and I just had this inner fire
that if you told me I couldn't do
something it just drove me even more to
want to do it and everyone you know at
that point in my life
that's probably four foot 11 and about
yesterday so when I told people I was
gonna become a seal they laughed me out
of the room and that just fueled me even
harder and I set my sights on that dream
and that's where I was going and you use
some of the things you did he started
playing football you started getting
involved in sports to make sure you were
physically fit and all that so that was
part of the driving factors part of any
good way to sort of prepare at least in
a minimum way for buds yeah absolutely I
mean I wanted to build a mindset I knew
that fitness I knew that being part of a
team I knew that pushing myself in
different areas so I started wrestling
and I started playing football and I was
the smallest guy on our team but man I
just I love football I've always loved
football my dad had always told me no
you're too small too small you're gonna
get hurt and so probably my 10th grade
year I said you know I don't care what
you're telling me I'm going out for the
team and thankfully we lived in a really
small town and I think they would take
anyone and they looked at me and they
said well you know we can at least use
you as a tackling dummy
and and I said Roger that I'll do it
Masamune oh I will
you know I'll hit somebody as hard as my
95 pounds camp and got out there and
just I love the sport you know I was you
know not a starter in any way but uh I
was out there every day just grinding
and I try and lay the hardest hit so I
could on people and I played receiver
and cornerback and nice yeah now I was
also a little bit as I read through the
book and was kind of piecing together
what you were like when you were kid I
got to this point here and she's kind of
a little bit of a different direction
going back to the book at the same time
I fell in with the wrong crowd I got a
job my junior year and my work friends
were drinkers I started sneaking out of
the house by sliding down the antenna
pole outside my window I'd meet with
friends we'd go drink I'd stagger home
drunk at odd hours of the night scaling
the side of the house with the help of
that pole my family tried to nudge me
into course correction but I had a chip
on my shoulder and refused to listen
especially to my dad things got worse my
relationship with my father and stepmom
spiraled out of control into the ground
months of this war us all down
that slide continued that that happens
right I mean that straight-up happens to
kids especially boys and I think it has
to do with I'm gonna prove myself that's
what I think hey I'm gonna prove myself
and one of the ways that you prove
yourself is by proving that you're
willing to sacrifice in a way and what
better way when you're 16 years old to
prove is like oh watch what I'll do I'll
drink I'll drink this whole bottle and I
think that leads to young males doing a
lot of dumb stuff and it sounds like
you're right on board absolutely you
know the thing that saved me though this
is where I got really lucky is I was
smart enough and and disciplined enough
to understand that if I got myself in
any kind of major trouble I wouldn't be
able to go in the seal to us so like I
said we lived in a real small town in
rural North Carolina and you know drugs
were prevalent and a lot of my friends
were starting to get into that and I
just said man if I get you know that'll
stop me from going in the Navy so at
least there was kind of a line I wasn't
willing to cross and I'm fortunate there
were a couple of times we got ourselves
in trouble where you know we were right
on the edge of the law being involved
and you know we managed to dodge that
bullet but yeah I wanted to get out
there I wanted to fit in so I think it's
a combination of both peer pressure as a
young man you know I want to fit in with
this group but I have my hopes and
dreams so this is the direction I'm
going and I think that's where a lot of
young men get off track they want to fit
in so much that they give up on their
hopes and dreams and they get sucked
down this path for me I had such a
little laser focus on what I wanted to
do that it at least kept me in check
yeah I will say this just to kind of add
to that point from my perspective if
you've got someone that's aspiring to do
something you know hire the people that
don't have those aspirations are more
than happy to try and crush that dream
for them and more than happy to pull
them down and so I've found that for
out life if you have some high
aspiration that you're trying to achieve
where you see someone that's got high
aspirations that they're trying to
achieve
you can watch the people around them if
they're not good people I'll try and rip
those things and pull them down and pull
them off that track scary and it's
unequivocally true I mean it's one of
the tenants you know I now speak on
something I call the Pentagon at peak
performance and the fifth level is or
I'm sorry the fourth level is social
leadership so how we lead ourselves how
we build our ring of friends and
influencers and and you're unequivocally
right a great influence or an
entrepreneur I've been recently working
with he gives an amazing analogy of he
was up in Alaska on a vacation he was
walking the beach and there was a
fisherman that was fishing with the net
and catching craps and he was putting
the craps in a bucket and you know it's
really morning and the guys name pedro's
Cooley and and bedros was watching this
happen you know early in the morning
looked in the bucket there was about 10
crabs then probably about you know 5
gallon bucket and probably about 8
inches of water and he kept watching
this one crap would climb up and grab on
to the edge of the bucket and try and
pull itself out and he like tells the
fisherman hey hey man dad I won't let
you know you're gonna lose one of your
crops and the fisherman doesn't even
turn around look at him keeps drawing
his net and he goes watch what happens
and bad rows kind of steps back and he
looks down into the bucket and he
watches is all the other crabs grab onto
that other crap and pull him back down
and he had this epiphany moment of the
circles of influence he had in his life
and he was like oh my god I have crabs
in my life he's like I have people that
I want to climb up and be better and
they're pulling me down and it is
unequivocally true I mean it's something
I brought up to the bud students
yesterday I said if you want to be the
best seal you need to surround yourself
with the guys who are driven disciplined
and they're pushing themselves to the
edge if you want to go to the next level
you need to surround yourself with the
guys who are either already there or
they aspire to get there because if
you're gonna surround yourself with
people who are content to just
drink and not move forward at all
they're gonna try and pull you into that
circle because they're gonna feel
threatened that you don't want to do
what they're doing and they want you to
assimilate with them burst driving
forward and being successful it's
unfortunate it's just kind of a way of
life it's a it's a horrible it's a
horrible situation so watch out for it
because it's everywhere so how did you
end up so you graduate high school and
go to recruiter and boom right I mean
any any other particular things around
the recruitment process
yeah the recruitment process was
actually I actually kind of got off
track a little so I went to the
recruiting station
I assumed as I decide I want to be a
seal I went to the recruiting station so
I was 15 years old that's 95 pound
weakling and walk into the recruiting
station and I'm like hey I want to be a
seal and there was an old crusty I mean
he was like an old school probably 25
years 6 and just crusty is all get out
you know boats ins mate and that dude
basically laughed me out of the office
was like get out of here stop wasting
our time you know you you couldn't even
carry the paddle much less the boat you
know get out of my office and it didn't
faze me in the least
I came back like next week and was like
I want to be a seal and they this guy
chased me out of the office I came back
about four or five times and he just
continued to not even give me the time
of day so finally I was you know kind of
tired of that I try the way things are
real rough when a recruiter won't give a
kid the time of day yeah take that quota
this is hardcore oh man yeah well I mean
you think about a 25 year he's six
yeah yeah he was at a point he didn't
really care so uh you know when I got to
the point I came back again probably
about eight months later and at this
point I'd you know really started
training I was focused on it I didn't
let him deter me and I came back and he
had left just by sheer happenstance he
was gone and there was a new recruiter
in there a guy by the name of Henry horn
Henry if you're out there and you listen
to this I've never been able to track
him down and thank him but Henry took me
in and was like yeah man absolutely
we sit down and had this video you may
remember this be someone special and it
was the cheesiest it was like nineteen
eighties video at at its best yeah and
and it was this high-speed you know the
shields come in on a helicopter and they
get out and they take down this target
and take out these terrorists and you
know the the tagline is be someone
special and I just ate it up man and
came back on a regular basis and and
Henry was fantastic he told me these are
the things you need to do you know as
bad fitness this is what's gonna happen
so went to went to go sign up you know
right as I was turning 17 I was gonna do
the delayed Entry Program and I went to
go sign up and went so I got back up for
a second there was a glitch I'm sorry I
got my facts backwards here I actually
because of the deal with the crusty East
six I was and him being a block to me I
changed my mind decided go army up first
Henry happened after this I'm sorry I
got that backwards Henry happened after
this and when I went back I decided to
join the army I said we'll find my dad
you know he was army the Rangers I'll go
the Green Beret route so I went to MEPs
to prot or to do my intake screening for
the army delayed Entry Program and I
failed the physical because when I was a
kid I had ruptured my eardrum and I had
a lot of scar tissue on my eardrum and
the army said oh well you're not gonna
be able to equalize so they tried to
convince me to still go in they were
like oh well you don't have to be an
Airborne Ranger you know you can do this
or you can do that you can drive trucks
and I was like nah man that's not what I
want to do so I left and I didn't sign
up and probably a couple months went by
and then that's when I came back and the
krusty e6 was gone and Henry Horne was
there and really helped pave that path
so kind of an interesting Road and I
think the lesson is this is there's
always going to be roadblocks that are
going to deter you from your dreams you
know don't let it stop you keep driving
forward because by you know if I just
listen to that guy right for
getting you know I never would have been
a seal sure yes you go in you show up at
Budds I like this is a good going back
to the book your your intro to buds one
night I was asked ordered to escort a
member of class 199 back to his room
building in 602 he'd quit the program
and the Navy required an escort for
anyone who rang the bell during hell
week I went off to find him in the
darkness he was waiting for me a smaller
guy like me wrapped in a blanket he was
shivering so badly he seemed ready to
fly apart he put the blanket over his
head like a hood giving him a monastic
look he said little so we made our way
to the barracks in silence I walked
alongside him fit fit to burst wanting
to get any details on what I'd soon
experience finally I couldn't stand him
anymore as he reached his door and
opened it I blurted it out so come on
man what was it like he turned to me and
looked me in the eyes his rooms night
light cast an orange glow across his
face his skin was waxing and he looked
hollowed out at length he answered in a
slow earnest tone dude it was so cold I
would have poured gasoline all over
myself and lit a match just so I could
have been warm for a few seconds before
I burned to death he stepped back
without another word and slammed his
door for the first time I wondered what
I got myself into as legit right there
is Row two buds so there's a so not only
did that blow my mind you know there's a
funny little side story we actually had
to edit that so the fire thing we
actually created because what he
actually he told me that exact thing the
so the dialogue is the same but what he
told me was about as vulgar as all
get-out it would have made the book
rated xxx and and it was so mind-blowing
because I mean you know the fire thing
we tried to come up with what is as
impactful as
but it does not convey I'll let your
imaginations run wild but what he told
me and he slammed the door in my face
left me so stunned I thought I was like
what the hell did I get myself into I
mean it was but we could not put it in
the movie you know it was so bad I mean
I was like my kids can never reach a
jack so anyways I mean then you get to
but you go through buds and buds is cool
and you you write about buds a little
bit in here but you don't spend a bunch
of time on it because as we know buds is
not a huge part of our careers and the
SEAL Teams and I'm gonna jump right
right ahead to the book here seven years
and three South American deployments
into my career as a seal I found myself
in Fort Knox Kentucky working as a basic
warfare instructor with a small group of
fellow operators we worked 18-hour days
but being 20-something and single once
the gear was stowed all we wanted to do
was get out on the town and blow off
some steam work hard play hard
that was our pre 9/11 mantra the 90s
teens work hard play hard I always have
to explain to people how cool it is
being in the teams being an e5 and the
teams what were you any five or any sex
at this point I was named v e5 and the
teams and I was telling the story the
other day this when I got to SEAL team
one there was AI was a new guy and I was
quietly walking through the locker room
trying to keep my eyes averted from
looking at anyone and I hear this guy go
ah yes and I was like oh my god and it
was this like barbaric yell from this
human being who is one and then I looked
at him and he was this monster guy
probably six seven six six 280 pounds of
tattooed flesh and someone's like what
happened and he goes I just made ye5
Master Chief as far as I'm concerned
so yeah you know you get to be an e5 in
the seal platoon you know you've got if
you if you're not looking for a lot of
responsibility you won't find it but you
won't you know you're a little bit above
some of the crap work so it's not a bad
place to be and that's where you were
doing doing deployment after deployment
three deployments to South America and
doing the training gig yeah were you at
training cell at the team at this time
or was it already consolidated no each
team had its own individual training
still yep I did that too and this is
also the time during one of these trips
where you met your future wife that's
right so you know you know the SEAL
Teams are an interesting place because
being an all-male unit you know the only
time you have an opportunity to meet
people ladies is typically in the bars
and because we did such a good job you
know I tell people the mindset of the
early teams really was you know you know
Marcinko captured that mindset in his
book the real warrior but it's
interesting to see post 9-11 how guys
and subways are focused on combat you
know but for us you know literally we
trained hard and then you know you were
actually looked down on if you didn't go
out and party and burn it down to like
4:00 in the morning and then get an hour
asleep and get up and start training in
the next day you know which was just
stupid you know you weren't operating at
optimal efficiency but that was just the
way it was that was life and accepted it
and drove through so yeah I was
fortunate enough one night we went into
a crazy huge bar that somebody had
scouted out and said hey man this is a
target-rich environment and the Phoenix
Hill tavern and went in there and yeah
beautiful blonde walked in and I was
like I need to get to know this young
lady you did all right man along along
the course of this you apply for the
seaman Admiral program which is the same
program I did I think you were a couple
years behind me and we're going to the
book I had applied to the seaman Admiral
program something the Navy started to
encourage top-performing enlisted to
become officers only 50 candidates a
year were accepted back then so the
competition was fierce
I gained a slot in the Navy sent me to
college just in time to miss the
outbreak of the war I watched the Towers
fall I recognized the magnitude of the
moment and left school in the days fully
aware that our country was heading to
war with 3 years of college ahead of me
I feared I'd missed my chance to be a
part of it a few days later I drove back
to my old SEAL team to see my former co
and mentor commander Vince Peterson he
had stuck his neck out for me more than
once and had been instrumental in
getting me a shot a slot in the seaman
admiral program I told him I wanted to
drop out of school so I could get back
to a platoon and help with the war
effort
commander Peterson sat listening quietly
as eeks as I explained my desire to come
back he was a legend in the SEAL Teams
he had been a former Marine before
joining the Navy and headed to seal
training at the age of 36 he was highly
respected both up and down the chain of
command in my leadership defense analogy
most men fell on one side of the fence
or the other while there were those
small few who had the unique ability to
stand on top and move back and forth for
Vince Peterson there was no fence as I
sat down with him and asked him to put
me back in the platoon he looked me dead
in the eye and said red this will not be
a short war it's going to go on for
years and we're going to need strong
warriors and leaders for upcoming
battles you need to stay in school then
come back and lead
Jack I when I read that of course I
thought about guess what I was doing
when 9/11 happened I was in college as
well on the same program that's probably
a year or two ahead of you and guess
what I did
same thing I called the detailer who was
a friend of mine who I had worked for
and I said hey I don't care about
college I'll do online I don't care
about any of this
send me back to a SEAL team right now
please and you know this individual too
is as well and I know who this guy is
and that he told me the exact same thing
he said this war is gonna last a long
time yeah of course I didn't believe it
and it you know and this is what's
interesting I recently saw the guy that
I called and I saw him and his wife who
I know his wife and she's a great person
and I was telling her this telling her
this and you know what she said it was
so awesome to hear she goes do you know
how many calls he got that day so there
was zero unique about jocko callin that
the seal detailer and saying sir get me
back to a team right now every single
guy that wasn't in a SEAL team in the
teams we everyone's gonna be billet of
any kind was called in the detailer and
said get back to a team
put me in coach yeah and it goes that
men tell her you're talking about we we
were we were just training and training
and training and be like training for a
game and training for the Superbowl
never get in the play yeah so you you so
you actually did a great job in college
and you you you were an ROTC too right
I was yeah see I got the real scam deal
where I just went to college and wasn't
wearing a uniform I was like far enough
ahead of you that I got the DNA you were
in the original program so you got
commissioned and went at school as an
officer see you get paid officer petty I
go to school I got the most ridiculous
deal I apologize to the taxpayers yeah
and the Navy quickly realized yeah okay
yeah we screwed this one up I think it
took them two iterations yeah I was in
because I think I was in the third
iteration third or fourth yeah but no we
actually were required to be a part of
ROTC so you know every day we were we
were up early and we and the Hampton
Roads NROTC at that time was the largest
ROTC consortium on the East Coast so you
had Hampton University you had ODU all
Dominion University at Norfolk State and
they had at that time probably about I
think we were at about 330 Midshipmen
and officer candidates and we had a huge
contingent of ex enlisted so there was
actually was probably six or seven seals
in the program there at that time so it
was good I had teammates to go through
with but yeah man we played all the
games and real quickly I realized I said
okay
you know they want it you've got to step
up you know they're gonna put you into
these different positions and a lot of
the guys that have come there before me
we're kind of like no dude we don't want
to do anything we don't want to be
involved we just want to you know a lot
of times typical team guys we want to
create our own little circle of of trust
and we don't want to let anybody else in
the circle and I was like nah man we got
to change that mindset you know there's
young kids here that we could influence
to become future frogmen I said and
because there was note that all these
communities at the school they had they
had you know surface warfare community
that had the aviation Club they had the
Submariner Club but there was no Special
Operations Club and there were young
kids who were interested and I said what
we need to create this you know we have
the experience we can help these kids
and then the other thing I said is I
said well you know I'm gonna try and
step up into leadership positions and I
think all the rest of us should do the
same and and thankfully you know it
worked we all jumped on board and
no I was fortunate I did excel in school
and I ended up leaving the school as the
student battalion commanding officer
prior to being commissioned to him
I was the regimental commander at
Officer Candidate School and that was
you know the number one position yeah
and I thought man yeah I was talking to
my mom and I mentioned - which I
shouldn't have done because my mom just
doesn't understand I was like well yeah
I'm you know I'm the the Reggie because
at the last couple weeks of OCS and I
she's not close to what's going on now
cuz then I could call because you
weren't allowed to call so I said well
we're doing this and I'm in charge of
the thing here it's called the
regimental commander and she goes oh
what he sir you're the commander and I
said um the regimental commander she
goes what are you in charge of and I
said I am overseeing the cleaning of
every toilet that Officer Candidate
School and it's going quite well so a
spotless spotless you see do you do
great job in college and now you go back
to the teams after college going back to
the book instead of having an advantage
I found myself left behind everything
had changed
and as our platoon went through its
training cycle I always felt like I was
playing catch-up I made mistakes and
exercises that I've never made in the
90s
it made me edgy intense feeling the
pressure of trying to be a leader and
drinking from that training firehose at
the same time I got tight and held on
even harder which only made things worse
in our time off I drowned my
frustrations and booze and routinely
routinely made an ass of myself none of
this was helping my credibility with the
men I was supposed to be leading but I
didn't see that at the moment it also
didn't help that senior chief Pete Kerry
and I despised each other almost from
our introduction he was a good skilled
SEAL and I respected his tactical
abilities but I felt his people skills
were lacking rough and abrasive at times
his leadership style clashed with
which set us on a collision course while
I privately railed against Kerry I was
too blinded by arrogance to see my own
flaws I wasn't making a good transition
to being an officer I'd been enlisted
for so long I identified with my
enlisted teammates more as one of them
rather than as one of their leaders it
put me too far away from the fence the
senior chief and the a oh I see are
supposed to work closely together to
make sure the team functions effectively
the Alic and that's assistant officer in
charge is also supposed to learn from
the Chiefs tactical experience that
never happened in our platoon instead I
refuse to humble myself and listen to
the senior chief as the pre-deployment
work up or on I wouldn't can we what we
couldn't conceal our dislike for each
other the feud spilled out into the open
and culminated with a public screaming
match in Europe after a tactical
exercise with some NATO allies in the
weeks that followed my arrival within
the team our relationship became the
cancer in our locker room by the time we
got to Afghanistan we refused to be
civilly to each other I had lost touch
entirely with what it meant to be a
leader during the daily briefs we would
openly take shots at each other I talked
about this dynamic many times with my
superior the platoons officer in charge
one day the OIC finally said look you
two have to work to this out I'm tired
of it
we never could or did work things out
different platoons structure things in
different ways in our platoon senior
enlisted members acted as fireteam
leaders with Chiefs and some more
experienced officers acting as the
assault force commanders I had been
assigned as neither if I had taken a
step back I might have realized that I
hadn't given my boss as much confidence
in my leadership but I didn't see that I
only felt slighted and embittered
roughed or yeah but all brought on by
myself I mean you know the dynamics
obviously created some interesting you
know problems but you know as often
happens I wasn't taking ownership
my own actions and instead was just kind
of trying to point fingers externally
well you know it's peak Gary's fault
that these things are happening when the
reality was 80% of it was me you know
80% of it
so it's one of the things that I talked
to a lot of individuals about I think
you see it in Special Operations I know
you and I both have spoken to
professional sports teams
I see it there where young men
accelerate quickly and achieved this
elite status and then get a little bit
of enamored with who they are and their
abilities and lose sight of the end
state which is to be an effective part
of the team to do their job so
ruthlessly well it plays this huge part
in the team and at the end of the day
whether you're in professional sports
whether you're the SEAL Teams or them
whether you're in some elite business
you know that's what has to happen and I
lost sight of that and more focused
externally instead of internally and
really now I speak a lot on what my
three rules of leadership is and the
foundational the first rule is lead
yourself and how you lead yourself 80%
of leadership is leading yourself you
know you talk so much about discipline
it's how you discipline yourself it's
how you structure yourself it's how you
push yourself it's how you set the
example and in doing so it automatically
leads to rule number to lead others it
almost makes it easy to lead others
because you've already done all the work
they want to follow you because you're
setting the example I kind of had it
backwards I was trying to lead others
but I wasn't leading myself and it's
almost impossible to do and I meet all
these people you know that I've gone out
in business and talked to him they say
Jay man how do I be a better leader and
you know my first question I always ask
them is how well do you lead yourself
because that's where I really really
failed we talk you know in the several
times you've mentioned a principle I
talk about called the leadership fence
and the leadership fence was just kind
of a concept that came up with after
watching a lot of really good leaders
and and bad leaders including myself in
that category you know years later I
looked back and the idea was this that
imagine a chain-link fence and and that
fence represents where you are in your
leadership journey and on one side of
the fence are all those you lead and on
the other side are those you report to
your superiors everybody has a natural
tendency to kind of fall on one side of
the fence or the other depending on how
they grew up or how they came into the
organization for me obviously when you
start out as an e-1 I connected a lot
more with the guys on the side of the
fence and I was leaning as a matter of
fact the team's back then typically
wanted to switch coasts with guys if
you're an analyst guy they won't send
you out to the opposite coasts and that
didn't happen for me and I tell you what
I look back on that now and I think that
was a mistake I you know I created a lot
of my own problems and the SEAL Teams
were right in their thinking on how to
do that because now the hardest
leadership often is pure leadership you
know to break through those bonds up hey
you and I were both friends but now I'm
in charge of you so how do we navigate
that waters and if you're close with
those people it makes it a lot more
difficult you know you have to be the
one that really has to break those bonds
and sometimes you know it can damage
friendships if you're not careful with
that and I think I was more focused on
retaining that so that was on one side
of the fence the other side of the fence
a lot of times you see individuals that
come into an organization later at a
higher leadership position so they get
brought in as an officer they get
brought in as a leader to a company and
they're most more focused on that
leadership position that they don't take
the time to get to know the people
they're leading so they're too far away
from the fence
it's a chain-link fence so that you can
talk through it so that you can
communicate through it and the best
leaders have the ability to be right up
against that fence so whether they're on
either side they're able to turn around
and gain guidance from the individuals
whether it's their leadership and
communicate it through to the
they lead or whether they're on the side
of communicating and interacting with
those they lead and communicating
through and getting guidance from who
they follow problems arise when you're
too far away from the fence you know the
leaders who are so far on the other side
of the fence at all they're thinking
about is how do I make the next rank you
know we know who they are I mean we've
seen those guys who literally you know
you think men you would like kill your
mother to make the next rank to be this
or be that and then we also know those
guys who you know they have no
aspirations to try and get better on the
other side of the fence and we you know
we joke about the career e5 so you know
they're perfectly content you know the
magic position and the SEAL Teams where
you know you're at that level where
you're high enough above to not do the
grunt work but you don't really have
tremendous responsibilities I was way
too far away no is the bottom line and
this is where I was tremendously failing
and not setting the example I wasn't
communicating with with the leadership I
was they were trying to provide me
guidance and basically saying hey dude
you're screwing things up and even even
Pete Kerry himself was trying to convey
to me in his very abrasive way hey dude
you know this is not the way you do
things but I was blinded both by having
excelled at this point in my career
really rocketing up and thinking oh I
know these things you know I'm the man
so humility is such a critical component
of leadership to take that step back and
if anybody's giving you advice always
take a second to think through it and
and you know evaluate hey even if maybe
you don't think it applies there's
probably pieces of it that do that's the
reality yeah I was with someone's giving
me critique points you know and of
course and it's every single I say every
single person on earth doesn't like
receiving critique like and I always
joke about the fact that even when
someone asks for criticism when they get
it they still get mad even when I say
hey Jay would you you know take read
this thing that I just wrote and tell me
what you think of it and then you read
and you say you know I thought it was a
little you could do
a little bit better I'm gonna be mad
right everyone gets mad and so that's so
what I do is the same thing I take a
step back when somebody gives me a
critique point even though I'm
completely offended and I don't agree
with them and I think I'm right because
I'm gonna give testicle maniac I put all
that aside and I say wait a second
there's a reason that they're telling me
this there's got to be some truth to it
I like I'm one of my favorite things
about this book is the fact that it it
reveals the the the difficulties that we
have in the SEAL Teams which are the
same difficulties that I see all the
time so people think oh and you're in
the SEAL Teams everyone's just perfect
and you know this this pee carry would
be the perfect mentor and he'd just be
able to come along and and then you'd be
the perfect recipient the perfect mentee
ready to learn and everything is just
perfect and and it's actually completely
untrue and what you have in the SEAL
Teams actually in the in like in the
civilian sector and companies and
organizations they have these
personality you know different
personalities in the SEAL Teams and so
you think own the SEAL Teams you don't
have that no you actually have it worse
because you've got these guys that have
that have really built their egos been
built up and we all think we're great we
all think we're a tactical genius we all
think we don't have anything to learn
and so so we have a lot of issues around
this exact kind of thing and it does
completely derail not just leaders but
it derails platoons and I I mean we
would disband platoons and when we would
disband a platoon that means the platoon
is no longer going to exist we'd have a
platoon coming through training level to
get disbanded it doesn't happen very
often but it happens yeah and when it
happens it hasn't has zero to do with
the ephors ePHI vests and usually the e6
is and it has 100% to do with the
seniority six is the Chiefs and the
officers inside the platoon that just
are disasters and it does happen and I
think the fact that you the the fact
that you talk through some of these
issues are I mean that's what that's
what you're very revealing about the
SEAL Teams in this book is like hey we
got you know we got the same issues that
they haven't
other or any other team any other
organization and that that you know that
thing that you talked about this this
fence you know that's to me that's the
dichotomy leadership right that's like
you can go too far in one direction or
the other and if you go too far in one
direction the other you're gonna you're
gonna fall apart
yep so check all right now you're on
deployment in Afghanistan and I always I
always mention this I haven't mentioned
it yet but I'll mention it right now
because I'm only reading small portions
of this book and there's so much more
great detail in the book and you'll have
a better understanding of these lessons
when you when you read the whole thing
so if it seems a little bit you know if
it seems it's jumping around a little
bit it's just because I'm only reading
chunks because I'm not gonna read the
whole damn book you can read it yourself
alright so now speaking of jumping
around you're in Afghanistan you had a
mission go down where it sounded like
you guys got some bad Intel and it
caused a little bit of a problem you hit
the target pretty hard and you guys got
put on an operational pause meaning hey
you guys aren't gonna do anything and
and that's a great story and how that
unfolds is great and people should read
so they can learn lessons from that but
then I'm gonna go skip a lesson here you
are in the chow hall and you're sitting
with some of your boys and I'm
specifically losing using that term
because at this point you definitely
were boys with the boys and I'm going to
the book I'd been searching for a way to
prove myself ever since I'd come aboard
now the opportunity to do so had just
fallen in my lap I had to take it in
time I learned there is nothing more
dangerous on the battlefield than an
immature and arrogant officer who feels
he needs to prove himself it can lead
men to their death and what you're
looking at is you happen to be sitting
in the chow hall with the commanding
general and these guys kind of your your
boys kind of egg you on to go talk to
him but hey why are we why are we
standing down and you're an ensign at
this point
okay so here we go I walked over and
stood beside the generals table excuse
me general
ensign Redmond Naval Special Warfare do
you have a couple minutes
his aides glowered up at me stamped on
their faces is who the hell are you look
that made me momentarily waiver the
general invited me to sit down his aides
looked frosted and grew more so after I
began to talk sir I just wanted to talk
to you about this operational pause we
still seem to be in I began the generals
face registering nothing but interest I
continued I know there was a
miscommunication with our first mission
but we know the enemy is out there and
we'd really like to take the opportunity
to go after them the general heard me
out then replied diplomatically well
ensign I've got to look at all the
strategic factors here we must always
weigh the strategic impact with the
impact on the civilian populace and
there are implications to going out and
operating at night I understand that sir
right now we're at a crazy time in the
war and we have to balance what we were
doing well general I said I can hardly
read that with a straight face well
general I said we really feel like we
can contribute in a positive way to by
going after the men who posed a clear
and present threat to coalition forces
when generals non-committal but remained
polite I don't think his aides took
their eyes off me through the entire
conversation I could feel them boring
holes through me I thanked them for
their time got up and headed back to my
table the other two operators were gone
why hadn't they stuck around get some
yeah beware of peer pressure and beware
you know once again it comes back to
that that lead yourself you know lead
yourself that founding principle because
you know this was a dangerous thing and
and and I did this several times during
that deployment you know this this
misunderstanding or this idea that
somehow there's this shortcut to being
an effective leader that there's this
push button easy button that beep look
at me now I'm a great leader and this
really was this moment and people
understand this was an interesting time
so this was this was July of 2005 so
June 28th the 2005 Operation Red Wings
had just happened and that was our troop
so we had lost you know we had lost five
of our guys including our troop
commander we had lost my Eric
Christensen we had lost my good friend
in the OIC in a platoon Mike mcgrevey I
originally was in Echo platoon we had
trained alongside those guys so we were
all grieving and we all wanted revenge
we all wanted to go after the enemy so
the very first mission we did was the
mission you talked about that got us in
a little bit of trouble so now take the
dynamics of everybody grieving because
of the loss of our teammates and and
then doing our first mission and being
put in hack because of really some
outstanding issues that you can read
about in the book we had actually done
everything right but it kind of got
placed back on us so I just you know
it's these moments that as a young
leader whether you're in a business
whether you're in the military law
enforcement whatever you do that you see
this shortcut oh look what I can do and
it got fueled when you know my teammates
and I sat there and started talking and
you know teammates were the biggest you
know shit talkers on the planet and
they they definitely were egging me on
and I ate it up hook line and sinker and
I was like you are absolutely right here
is a great opportunity for me to you
know shed some you know amazing wisdom
and insight to this general where he now
is going to be like Oh young ensign
you're so right
we should absolutely allow you guys to
go out and conduct all these operations
because I'm you know I'm not smart
enough to allow this to happen I mean
they're the arrogance that I had and
really sad that I didn't think through
you know what are the implications of
this you know for you to go do that I
mean it was just a stupid decision and I
realized it as soon as those guys were
gone like all the sudden I'm like what
did you just do moron
and as I walk back from the chow hall to
to our you know our camp I was like this
isn't going to go you wouldn't told your
boss that you did it I did I went
straight back to my CEO and I said hey I
want to let you know what just happened
I said I thought it was a good idea and
I don't think it was and you know it was
funny he kind of looked at me and he
said why why did you think that was a
good idea and and I said well I was you
know I was doing it for the boys it's
about the boys and you know so he really
was at the end of the day it was about
me and that's where you know really
understanding that you know in
leadership you are the last point in the
equation and don't get me wrong you know
there's an overlap of everything that
happens that we do so oftentimes you're
focused on the mission you're focused on
the man and of course by doing that well
there is a positive impact for you and
there's nothing wrong with that but that
thought process it should be it should
be by sequence if you will not because
you're focused on it ya know a hundred
percent and you're right the byproduct
of focusing on your people and focusing
on your mission the byproduct of that is
you'll be successful
and the contrary the the contrary in
situation is literally if you focus on
yourself instead of your people and your
mission you will fail you will you and
you know what fails a strong word
because there's people and you and I
know him who have focused on themselves
and they they they can win this battle
and they can win this tactical battle
they go in this tactical battle and they
can get to a certain point but
eventually it will come back on them and
you won't be as truly successful as if
you would as you would have been had you
focused on the men the mission and not
focused on yourself I call those people
leadership wrecking balls there's good
they're good at what they do you know in
some ways Pete Carey is one of those
people he was very good at what he did
and he got things done but he had a
tendency to leave and a lot of
organizations have these individuals and
they keep them around because they do
get things done but they leave a path of
destruction behind them and over time
people don't want to work with them and
you know that's why I call them the
leadership wrecking ball so you know I
tell people you need to evaluate
yourself are you one of those people do
you turn around you know forward you
look at the successes you have but you
turn around and look and there's a path
a destruction going away there no doubt
about it
all right so you guys eventually do get
back in the game you the the pause
operational pause gets lifted and you
guys are operating again and here you
are out on an operation you're in an
overwatch position on a hilltop going
back to the book between bursts of
gunfire I heard and rapport troops and
contact troops in contact
we're facing at least 20 enemy fighters
a wash of Static followed then I heard
joker add one of our afghan soldiers is
wounded we need reinforcements Jay
here's your chance your teammates are in
trouble I looked down into the valley a
thousand feet below the slope was steep
perhaps 60 degrees in places getting
down there would be a serious climb once
at the bottom
we'd have to maneuver to the sound of
the guns through broken terrain and
vegetation that would complicate
approaching our guys without getting
shot by accident I called to Fred and
asked if the Western overwatch team was
still in
place gunfire erupted over the radio as
he keyed his mic and answered I think so
okay good
that gave us eyes above and control over
the high ground over there this is the
moment Jay go prove yourself as we
dropped off the lip senior chief Carrie
called to me over the radio and wanted
to know what I was doing we're going
down I told him he went ballistic
absolutely not
we need to link back up fall back the
boys needed help and we were closest if
it had been anybody else I might have
thought twice about his call but my own
personal quest to prove myself coupled
with my intense hatred for him clouded
my judgment I ignored him and we pressed
on as we dropped further into the valley
we lost all communication with the
headquarters team I began to realize
what a hairy situation I had just placed
the two of us in we had given up the
high ground to move down a thousand feet
of vertical terrain to try and link up
with an element under fire with an enemy
force almost one kilometer away I pushed
this thought to the back of my mind the
boys need help focus on that but where
was the fight the sounds of battle
echoed all across the valley making it
difficult to calculate distance and
direction a broken transmission filled
my earpiece I couldn't tell what it was
but I recognized JD's voice I tried to
establish contact a moment later through
washes of static JD's voice came back
where the hell are you
JD demanded I told him we were at the T
intersection on the valley floor
get your ass out of the valley now he
said with so much anger I could almost
feel a blast of fire shoot out of the
earpiece I was about to explain my
intent when he added those guys are in a
major fight and we can't call in close
air support because we don't know where
you are that shook me there were
aircraft overhead waiting to join the
battle with rockets and bombs yet they
could not make their runs because of my
decision to go into the valley I should
have thought about our air assets but I
was too blinded by a my own ambition
with my combat experience on full
display
it started to dawn on me at last had I
made a mistake what if somebody got hit
during the delay I'd caused I keep my
radio and reported that we would be
pulling out of the valley and climbing
up the North Face of the t-intersection
to link up with our element there once
we were consolidated on the North Ridge
and our security was set for what would
surely be along that ahead JT came
looking for me
as he approached I could see he was
livid what the hell were you doing
indignant Lee I told him I was trying to
go to the aid of my brothers he looked
at me like I just spit on his wife that
was a stupid thing you did read you
could have gotten people killed his
words made me even more righteously
indignant I fired back at him the boys
were in trouble and I went to their aid
I did want to needed to be done in the
moment Jadey refused to accept that I
tossed out a similar situation that
occurred in Afghanistan a few years
before as if establish establishing
precedence would help my case
JD knew of the mission - and he cut me
off with not the same at all red they
didn't have air support available I
didn't know I know we did I shouted back
you delayed it with what you did JD
roared at last when it was clear to JD
that his words were not sinking in he
ended the argument curtly he said we'll
deal this when we after when we get back
to Kandahar he turned and stalked off I
watched him leave and struggled with my
own thoughts had I really made that big
of a mistake
no no way I went to help when is that
ever wrong
bro that's rough you know a lot of
people read that section who don't have
tactical background and they don't fully
understand they're like oh man no you
did the heroic thing you know you went
down into the battle you know you tried
to take the fight to the enemy but you
know I try to explain to them you know
you don't have a tactical understanding
you know there are so many things that
were done wrong there that it literally
and this story would be so different if
something that actually happened and the
potential for something to have gone
wrong is through the roof I mean you've
been in Afghanistan I mean you know the
fighting positions and basically I took
myself off a very advantageous high
ground position that we owned down into
the valley a thousand feet below I mean
there could have been hundreds of
fighting positions and caves above me
that any one single fighter could have
just decimated us and you know would
have been one thing if I got myself
killed but I pulled a young team guy
machine gunner down with me so I placed
this guy's life in jeopardy and you know
I the the funny thing is you know I
tried to paint it in that moment arguing
with JD that I was doing the right thing
I'm taking the fight to the enemy I'm
you know supporting my brothers and all
this BS you know the reality was I
wanted to get in the fight at that point
I had been on the edge of a lot of
firefights and and you know and even in
fighting I mean until you get in there
you haven't proved yourself and I wanted
to prove myself I wanted to prove myself
both as a seal as a fighter and as a
leader and this was another moment just
like the general where I thought here's
my opportunity and and I was so
unwilling to listen you know that I had
made a mistake and the reality is if I
had to owned it in that moment it
probably would not have been as bad as
it was but the mere fact that I just
planted my flag on that spot and was
like screw you you're wrong I'm
and I did the right thing I think just
turned what was a fire into a raging
inferno yeah yeah no that's that's
definitely rough and I think also from
from a tactical perspective people make
mistakes like this like it can happen
and it can happen and and you know I
talked about being able to detach and
that's something that I definitely
learned in the SEAL Teams and it was I
think one of the most advantageous
skills for a leader especially a combat
leader to have is to be able to to step
back from the situation as its unfolding
because if you fully knew hey we've got
air overhead and they're in a firefight
and if I go down there we won't be able
to use air support you wouldn't have
done this even even a 60 gunner you know
even a pig gunner would say okay no I
need to I need to let that that unfold
but you know you're exciting to get down
there and and get in the fight is
definitely you know that's something
that that can grab a hold of anyone if
they're not careful and and again it's
what we just talked about with you at
that moment put yourself ahead of the
mission ahead of the team and and then
yeah I mean this idea of ownership and
and you know when I when I kick off the
book that I wrote with life extreme
ownership you know kicks off with a blue
on blue and you know is it was a lot of
bad things happening there was a lot of
moving parts going on it was a horrible
situation an Iraqi soldier got killed
several more got wounded one of my guys
got wounded and I can tell you right now
like I think if I would have said hey
this wasn't my fault blame it on someone
else I think I would have gotten fired
about in about three seconds because
it's just it's a bad situation to unfold
and yeah you planting the flag on that
is is rough and and III mean your
humility and putting this out there is
awesome and people can learn so much
from that because if you recognize how
easily you and you
okay let's let's let's let's paint you
in a bad light that you were young and
you were but let's paint you in a good
light even with you had those qualities
of being hyper aggressive and you want
to get in the fight and you're a little
bit arrogant
you're still a team guy that's trying to
do a good job it wasn't like we were
trying to do a bad job so to recognize
like hey even if you're well-intentioned
if you don't pay attention to these
things they can grab hold of you and
they can pull you in the wrong direction
and and you look up and and you're
you're you're planting your flag and and
putting up your defenses around an
indefensible position which is where you
ended up here and and you nailed it with
the idea you know it's something I know
you talk to people about a business I
talk about I think it's no different
probably I'm fighting you know you've
got to let the battlefield develop
sometimes we have this natural instinct
that when something bad happens when a
crisis happens we feel this you know oh
my god I got to react immediately before
we actually take the time and even in a
gunfight you typically have a few
seconds and it's amazing how much
information we can process in a few
seconds before we react and move and so
that was one problem and the other
problem and you know was I was driven by
this relationship issue and it's funny
you know the individual the retired
Master Chief that you were with on you
know Thursday who was I served under him
twice later we had talked about that
exact situation and he had given me
advice later and he said never let your
personal feelings get in the way of your
professional relationships and I had I'd
absolutely let my personal feelings
drive that and that was probably the
biggest fu moment you know like I said
if it had been anybody else but my
hatred for him had grown to the point
that I was just like yeah let me show
you buddy you know and so all these
things you know dangerous you know that
not only did you know all these things
you have to be careful of it I mean this
is what falls under you know a lot of
people call these different things and
my Pentagon a peak performance I call it
emotional leadership so your ability to
attach yourself for a second and say
okay I'm not gonna let my own personal
feelings drive this because what's going
on around me my ability to lead and make
the right decisions is more critical
than what I feel and obviously you know
I have not learned those lessons yet I
was on that on that glide path and at
this point I was on the glide path down
I was crashing and Bertie
ruff-ruff going back to the book back at
Kandahar I heard the first whispers
about me floating around the team the
men had nicknamed me Rambo red though
some may think being compared to
Stallone's lone-wolf silver screen icon
was a compliment within our community it
was a supreme insult in the SEAL Teams
there's no room for individualism
foundations of our success rest on
mutual cooperation and communication a
lone wolf like Rambo could destroy a
team with catastrophic effects on the
battlefield after we debrief the mission
JD Richardson took me into his makeshift
office and said read your operational
abilities have been called into question
we're sending you back to Bagram to meet
with the SEAL and we'll discuss this
further when the rest of the team gets
back I was stunned at worst I was
starting to expect something more than a
wrist slap but nothing like that I was
being sent back to the rear out of
combat nothing can ever be more
humiliating for a warrior I trained my
entire adult life for this and now I had
been told I didn't measure up I felt
like a mule kick to the gut I heard
rumblings that senior chief Kerry wanted
to see my Trident taken away behind the
scenes he was pushing for a Trident
Review Board to determine my fate the
months of infighting between us had been
bad enough now he was trying to destroy
my career
I was sick at the thought of losing my
Trident over a single bad moment in the
valley whose name nobody back home would
ever know and whose location would not
matter to anyone but a handful of men
who had fought in it
ensign Redmond had to Semin strated a
consistent pattern of bad
decision-making I thought again about my
screaming match with senior chief Carrie
during the NATO exercise when it ended
what did I see in the eyes of him what
did I see in the eyes of my teammates
embarrassment this wasn't really about
one moment in the valley was it Jay I
had to face that fact I rubbed my inking
temples
I felt like my head was going to explode
from the pressure building inside of it
my life was being destroyed and I had
made myself vulnerable to these attacks
with my own actions if I was allowed to
continue to operate stories of this
deployment would circulate through the
teams if I go to my next platoon with my
reputation in tatters who would follow
my lead
sitting neatly on the wooden crossbar on
the floor beside my bed my holstered sig
sauer p226 sat well oiled and cleaned I
leaned over and pulled it out I knew
around was already in the chamber but I
drew back the slide and took a look to
make sure we called a suppressed check
and it confirmed what I already knew my
gun was ready to go as I held the pistol
I thought of the great samurai warriors
who if disgraced would commit ritual
suicide part of me will my hand to raise
the sig to press it firmly to my temple
my life is over there's nothing left but
an honorable exit I glanced over at the
desk and saw a picture of my beautiful
wife Erica the image of her face riveted
my attention her easygoing smile her
eyes alight and lively always quick to
laugh and offer love and compassion what
would this do to her after all she'd
sacrificed for me would my death snuff
out the life of her gorgeous eyes
with the bullet I put in my temple I'd
leave her the burden of my failed career
and a ticket
to a lifetime of grief the kids would
live under that cloud as well
you know it's interesting a lot of
people who have not read my book or
maybe they have read it and they gloss
over this but they will wrongly assume
that my injuries and that ambush in the
aftermath of that ambush were the
hardest thing I've ever been through and
and I tell him absolutely not
by far that that moment right there in
that period of time in my life about a
that was about a four month period
maybe five months that that journey to
the bottom and I was almost at
rock-bottom at that point and this is
where the psychology of humans is an
interesting thing because all of us have
that little voice that lives inside of
us
I call mine my demon and my demon has
been my greatest pusher because he tells
me what I can't do and he also at times
can be the most dangerous thing out
there because they will push you to do
things are wrong they will push you to
do things and tell you you can't do
things and it was in that moment that I
literally was listening to that that you
know you will never recover you you know
your career is over there's no way
you're gonna come back from this the
guys are never gonna follow you again
all these lies these are lies that we
tell ourselves and I think it's really
important you know if there's anything
about me I tell people that I am I am an
expert on overcoming adversity failure
in crisis and it doesn't matter how bad
things have been you always can recover
it goes back to those three rules of
leadership you just once again go back
to leading yourself and in that moment
though I was so crushed so crushed
because I had convinced myself that I
had done the right thing and and
unfortunately I still believed that nice
just saw myself as a victim
a victim who had no way that I can
recover and you know it's sad and and
you know you know that God moment that I
glanced over cuz I don't think if if I
had made the mistake or wherever I was
I'm not having pictures and my wife and
kids right there I probably would have
done it cuz I just felt so hopeless and
then I was ashamed honestly for thinking
that and thinking about the impact I
would leave on them so I'd love to say
that was the catalyst of starting to
climb out of that hole but I actually
continued to spiral down over the next
couple of months until finally you know
my nor you know that moment occurred
right after you know my judgment had
been set upon me which really I was very
fortunate because I should have been
grateful because really what they could
have done is said you're out of here
yeah you know we're sending you out of
the teams you're gonna go before try to
review board and they didn't you know
the CEO believed in me he said you know
you've done a lot of great things you've
had some amazing moments you've just
you've got some flaws you've got some
arrogant flaws and you definitely we
need to work on your decision-making
leadership abilities so that's what they
did it's it's you know when I was
reading this part be it's it's gonna be
it's it's I don't really I don't think
you could have I don't think a human
being I don't think you could explain I
don't think Will Shakespeare could
explain to someone that's not in the
team's what it feels like to be in the
teams and to feel like maybe that's not
gonna be your life anymore that's rough
man
and I don't think he I mean you did your
best and like I said I don't think it's
just to to explain and I mean I guess
you do it because you explain listen you
were at a point where if you couldn't be
in the team's you didn't want to be
alive that's where you were at right
there and I guess that does explain it I
think it might be hard for people to
relate to but like for people like you
and me that grew up literally whole
adult life in the SEAL Teams
I can't even imagine if at the in the in
the in the highlight of that moment of
being deployed in combat you just lost
your comrades and arms from your task
unit and to be told okay you can't do
this job anymore
I mean like you said and again I think
it's gonna be hard for people to
understand that it seems like you you
would never want to you wouldn't want to
live at all and then just to add this on
to what you're saying and I say this
every time that I talk about these kind
of personal storms that people get into
and I've just got to say this in case
someone hasn't heard me say it before
when you're in that storm it seems like
it's goes forever in every direction
anyone on the outside would anyone 10
feet away from you would look at you and
say oh yeah you're you made some
mistakes you need to you need to get
back on the horse you need to get back
out there here's what's gonna help you
get fixed there's will get you back up
but when we reach every direction you
look is black and you think you're not
getting out and team guys don't play
around either at all going back to the
book I you so you decide okay I'm gonna
I'm gonna stick it out you're on your
way back I've made my way back to my
hooch
when I entered our living quarters I
walked by our message board and saw a
note scrawled next to my name why don't
you go ahead and kill yourself I stared
at the words for I don't know how long
the hallway was empty nobody had been
standing around waiting to see my
reaction that's team guys there's no
mercy in the seal platoon there's not
you know I've often thought about that
and and you know the deal we have
incredibly dark humor so I often wonder
was somebody just trying to lighten the
mood and kind of shock me into hey dude
come out of it you know go fix yourself
I've always I've often wondered that or
were they serious and just like dude
you're a disgrace
yeah we don't and and I know for a fact
I mean there was a point right before we
left on that deployment a couple weeks
later where you know guys were being
divvied up into where there
going next so neckla tune its next
leadership and they were asked you know
who who do you want to work with you
know who do you want to work under and
and they unequivocally wrote we don't
want to work with red so this was an
additional blow that really kind of
reinforced him in you you you got some
you got some work to do except I'll be
honest I wasn't at that point yeah you
weren't there yeah I was still at rock
bottom you know you talked about the
storms I talked about life ambushes and
this was a major life ambush one of the
first major life ambushes I'd ever
encountered and I literally was on the
acts taking withering fire and I
couldn't figure out how to get out of it
and you were doing your best to return
fire with your pistol in this case I was
gonna return one round thinking that was
gonna fix things I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
right yeah I'm gonna maintain this
position right here and I'm gonna win no
actually you're not you need to you need
to look around you need to maneuver so
you do end up keeping your Trident
because obviously there were some guys
that that believed in like you said
believed in you and saw that you had the
potential and actually sometimes people
ask me what makes a guy get fired or not
get fired and for me it's like almost
100 percent if the guy lacks humility
they're gonna get fired or if they if
they if no one if I would see a guy that
had no humility whatsoever and I didn't
see a crack it'd be like okay this guy's
a lost cause he's never gonna listen
anyone you can't coach someone that's
lacks humility completely so or you
can't help them maybe they're gonna sit
and on the X and just get shot up that's
the way it's gonna be
so somebody saw that hey we can get
through to this guy you know he's a good
team guy and more importantly to that
point and this is a great leadership
point an organizational point not only
are they gonna sit there and take those
hits because they're too arrogant to be
willing to move they're gonna pull
everybody else down with them and that's
where it gets really dangerous I mean
especially in our community where lives
are on the line
I mean if they're unwilling to learn or
humble themselves enough they're gonna
get somebody else killed and that was
the big concern at that point and man
I've got to give kudos to my commanding
officer who is a friend of this day he
saved my career because I was an
exhibiting humility though I was
fighting back I was I did the right
thing I'm the victim here you know I'm
just being thrown under the bus and
thankfully he had enough faith in me I
guess he had seen enough good that he
said I think we can fix him you know
good man
and one of the things that they do to
fix you in the SEAL Teams is send you to
Ranger School a wonderful vacation for
back and I would say there's a small
there's some people that go to Ranger
school cuz they want to go to Ranger
School right on but oftentimes in the
SEAL Teams Ranger School and I wouldn't
even call it punishment but it's it's
like a reeducation and that's definitely
something that has always been and
that's what they do with you okay
they're gonna they're gonna send you to
a really tough training school where
it's not just a tough training school
where you get weeded out you learn some
tactics you learn to you learn
leadership and I did not go to Ranger
school but you know it's a great school
everyone I know that the Rangers that I
know are awesome guys so great school
but often times we use it in the SEAL
Teams maybe punishment is the wrong word
in some cases I know it's been
punishment occasionally a guy I'll want
to go there but generally guys I mean
generally guys are working so I'm not
gonna go to Ranger School you end up
getting the Ranger school and here we go
sick hungry burning with resentment
because as you said you're not you at
this point you're still like all this is
this this is crap I don't deserve this
yeah I was bit to say I was bitter is an
understatement yeah burning with
resentment I went into the first few
days with without my heart or mind
engaged the first week of Ranger School
is nothing but a gut-check long days of
minimal sleep exposure the elements and
constant physical and mental evolutions
to get those who don't want to be there
to quit teamwork leadership within a
circle of peers and decision making
under stressful conditions were the
objective of this first phase as a seal
should have represented my community in
the best possible manner while by
displaying leadership a commitment to
teamwork and a willingness to overcome
obstacles
instead my actions showed me to be
arrogant ill-tempered and unwilling to
work with others many soldiers falsely
believed that seals are like that and my
actions we simply reinforced it I failed
to represent my community as anything
but that stereotype so you have this bad
attitude you go out on a compass course
you're pretty good at land nav you think
you're gonna kick ass you don't kick ass
you do a bad job the black hats who are
the Ranger instructors here we go the
black hats chuckled with laughter damn
squid got lost we should have given you
a boat swabby another growled not
surprising seals don't know how to
navigate anyways I failed it's something
I once took great pride in not so good
without your Gucci gear are you another
sneered I lost it all my pent-up fury
frothed out of me
screw this course and screw you kiss my
ass I walked up to my company instructor
and told him I'm out of here I quit
are you sure you want to do that without
thinking I said yes I was reading this
book and I was like Dave I was damned I
mean holy shit yeah talk about a total
breakdown of emotional leadership I mean
that's the reality iodide and and here's
the problem with that I had allowed this
to happen by not managing myself I had
allowed this I was like a pressure
cooker waiting to pop off and instead of
managing it and recognizing and come to
grips with it I I didn't and it it just
manifested itself in that moment where I
failed the land nav course because of my
own arrogance and then you know I
allowed those Ranger instructors to get
under my skin in that failure instead of
immediately saying well hey no big deal
I could have gone back and done it again
like three days later cos er I wasn't
the only guy that failed there were
other guys that failed but instead of
that I instantly just it was one
additional
below that I had sustained and being at
this tipping point you know I allowed
them to get under my skin and snapped
and it is the only thing I have ever
quit in my life that I have verbally
quit I mean for all intents and purposes
I rang the bell in that moment and so
angry and frustrated and listened to
that demon that said your career is over
you will never recover from this you
know this is the final straw you know
you had an opportunity and you missed it
man so you know nobody's never gonna
follow you again
yeah and everyone screwed you over and
put you in this point absolutely that's
why you know victim victim victim
mentality now this is a miracle this is
a miracle this niggas god moment you
know I don't understand this this is a
miracle the colonel in charge of Ranger
School happens to be friends with Vince
Peterson who we talked about earlier and
that's not his real name but he's a
legendary seal officer and a prior
Vietnam Marine battle away City by the
way just a just an awesome guy and for
whatever reason miracle the Colonel
that's in charge of Ranger School is
friends with with captain Peterson and
here we go going back to the book you're
sitting there talking to the colonel
Vince Peterson was the greatest natural
leader I'd ever known he had a knack of
expressing where the team needed to go
with just a few words he'd plant seeds
like his men taking ownership of the
plan then watched as everything went
forward with the plans when the plan
succeeded and it almost always did he
never took the credit he gave it to
everyone else in retrospect I'm not
proud that all I could manage was the
fable and this goes back to something
you talked about earlier in the book but
at this point I was still unable to face
the truth myself let alone admit it to
the leader I respected above all others
and so here you go your conversation
with Captain Vince Peterson read do you
really think Ranger School is punishment
it is sir
read have you ever thought that maybe
there is an opportunity here sir you
have a chance to learn something of
value if you're willing to take it I
didn't know what to say to that I had
not been trying to learn anything since
Afghanistan I've been trying to defend
and justify you're getting ready to
throw your career away read I'm not sure
I have a career left sir read he said
firmly what are you gonna do if you get
out if you come back you'll be out of
the Navy in a month how are you going to
support your family he let that sink in
I had no answer in stayed silent besides
do you really want to go through your
life having ended your career this way
you can recover you control your destiny
and your future you can earn back the
respect of the guys if you give them
something to respect if your actions
demand respect I hadn't looked at it my
situation from that angle read get back
in that course finish it then come back
with your head held high and show that
you have the ability to lead that'll
leave a mark
yeah well and you know for people to
understand I I didn't sleep a wink that
night after I after I quit and I was so
ashamed of what I had done and I was so
convinced that there was no way I could
undo it that I literally was just
resigned to the fact that my career was
over right and when I went into that
office I first spoke to the sergeant
major and the sergeant major asked if I
wanted to speak to anybody in the SEAL
Teams hell no man I don't want to talk
to anybody you know I am a failure I am
you know broken and and then it was the
colonel who asked me and I said the same
thing so the mere fact and this is he
didn't even offer
he just started dialing so that and the
mere fact you talk about this bait
moment that that Vince Peterson will
happen to be at his phone an answer
right then
and and then saying being on the phone
and him to hand it to me and there was
no way in hell I mean I had such respect
for this this man there was no way I
could say no and you know that
conversation you know this is this is
the highest levels of leadership to be
able to quickly analyze a situation
especially when you're working with
people to understand you know okay this
is where we're at this is the
battlefield I'm looking at this is what
I have to work with and this is what I
need to do to move this person to where
we're going to motivate and inspire them
and I mean he did it flawlessly you know
exactly what to tell me he told me both
the good and the bad he gave me hope and
he told me what happens if you don't
which would be hopeless you know I will
have you out of the military in less
than a month and then you know I tell
people that is the most succinct and
powerful leadership advice I've ever
been given you know people will follow
you if you give them a reason to if you
give them something to respect and that
really is the foundation of you know the
three rules of leadership I talked about
lead yourself that's 80% of it you know
leading others comes naturally and he
was right because I left that office and
the the funny thing about it though is I
got off the phone and I asked the
colonel I said sir would you put me back
in class and he didn't miss a beat no he
said instead you will go to the holding
company and we will class you up with a
new class a month later which is just
what you needed you get rolled back for
30 days going back to the book I bent
down and picked up the cigarette but
lying in the grass at my feet with a
flick the bus spun to the garbage bag
I'd been dragging across post with me so
here you are a combat seal officer
picking up cigarette butts 13 years and
13 years in as I filled my bag with
litter the bit bitterness flared again
I've put 13 in I've put in 13 and a half
years I was a member of one of the most
elite Special Operations units in modern
history millions of dollars were spent
preparing me training me outfitting me
to handle the toughest battlefield tasks
our nation can face and my own brothers
have reduced me to this I
stop and thought about that statement
where was the personal responsibility in
it
Vince Peterson's word came back to me
you have an opportunity to learn here if
you're willing to take it I served with
good men whom I respected they turned
their back on me
or did they what did all this say about
me a door suddenly opened in my mind the
place it led to was a dark room that I
had never entered inside I could see the
truth about myself through the facade of
lies I had built I stood at its
threshold not really wanting to walk
through sunsoo once said if you know
your enemies and you know yourself you
will never be defeated I didn't know
myself I was running blindly through
life refusing to even acknowledge my
weaknesses I have been an arrogant ass
most of my career clearly I needed to
come down to earth maybe trash detail
did serve a purpose after all I guess I
needed to mentally flatline before I
could reconstruct my self for leadership
I found another cigarette butt inflicted
into my back the bitterness over being
forced into this sort of work evaporated
far from a humiliating burden it was
giving me clarity I surely needed for
years my attitude had hobbled
relationships and endangered my career I
suddenly recalled a moment years before
I had worked my tail off for months on a
special project when I finished it I
knew I was gonna receive a significant
award for the effort for whatever reason
it got downgraded to a lesser award what
did you do after you found out I've
thrown a temper tantrum I went off on
one of our admin guys who had
congratulated me after I received it
instead of being grateful receiving any
sort of acknowledgment I'd thrown the
awarded him I might as well have thrown
it in the face of captain Peterson who
was my CEO at the time that incident
stuck with my peers who witnessed it
and four years after when I ran into one
of them they'd remind me of it
Jason Redman Navy Achievement Medal
thrower Vanguard of leadership I can't
say I looked forward to picking up trash
the next morning but I didn't start the
day despising what would come next I was
ashamed that I had thought so highly of
myself that I saw myself as above
picking up trash I realized that as a
seal leader it was my responsibility to
accept the example with everything I
undertook there you go there you go it
was you know so this is probably the
point and I talked to a lot of people
about this like I I wish I could say
that after I hung up the phone with
Captain Peterson that I went back and
was like you know yeah let's go let's do
this you know let's crush this and
instead I still was kind of finishing I
was on that slope down to crash that
plane and I finally crashed that plane
and hit really the bottom of the barrel
and and it was at that point that I
really started to analyze myself this
someone I talked to a lot of people
about you know you truly have to know
yourself you cannot because our
weaknesses manifested themselves in the
hardest times they don't come out in the
good times and the good times there's no
issues with it and the only way you
could manage that you know is to a
mental leadership and emotional
leadership at the highest level because
in the hardest times and usually those
are the time so you got to be managing
the most is when it comes up and it was
by really starting to rip myself apart
and look at you know all these things
that I had done and understanding oh
yeah when I get into these situations I
feel that you know that that meltdown
with the Ranger instructors you know I
felt that coming on I could have stopped
it but I didn't I let it go
you know they lift the fuse and instead
of tamping it you know ow
I let it burn and blow up so it was you
know really it was these moments and
this is probably
biggest thing that I can tell anybody
out there it is never too late you can
always come back so for four months I
had convinced myself that I was a victim
for months I convinced myself there was
no way to do this and for the first time
when I finally looked at you know these
are your weaknesses but oh by the way
man you've got some amazing strengths
and you know you need to figure out how
to amplify these strengths minimize
these weaknesses and and what an
opportunity you have you are a seal
that's in Ranger school
that couldn't crush this course set the
example and come back every day is
another opportunity you're gonna screw
up again and that's okay but you know so
for the first time I saw Hope standing
at the rock bottom and looking up
through this tunnel I saw a glimmer of
light well what's what's when you say
that what I think about is what people
get themselves into they box themselves
into this scenario and it's exactly
where you had boxed yourself into which
was hey look this guy doesn't like me
this guy's blaming me for that this
these people have a bad attitude and
you're in and guess what other people
you can't control and so you end up in a
hopeless situation because I can't
change this guy's attitude he's an
asshole he doesn't like me he whatever
we had a run in this person they don't
trust me and I can't change that and so
when you're in a situation where you
can't change the situation at all
because you don't have control over any
of it well then guess what you're
hopeless but the minute you look at
yourself and you say wait a second I
actually control everything that's going
on right now everything people's
perception of me is based on my behavior
not theirs and that's what that's what I
liked what up what Peterson said you you
control your destiny in your future
that's that that to me I highlighted
that 98 times you control your destiny
in your future and at this point in the
book is where you saw and it took you
cigarette butts in it took you to that
point where you say wait a second all
these things that have happened to me I
can get control of them and I can turn
them in a better direction and yeah
that's awesome and the journey began
yeah that you can't expand a little bit
more here I could not I could not change
my decision but I should you're talking
about this is what you're talking about
you're reflecting now on what happened
on your decision to go into the valley
in Afghanistan that whole scenario that
you got in trouble for here's what you
said about it I could not change my
decision but I should have owned it in
its aftermath I should have listened to
those with more experience taking my
lumps and moved forward that is how
leaders grow I was so desperate to
justify and defend my actions I lost
sight of what to do of what I was there
to do I was there to lead when necessary
and to follow and called upon but above
all else to accomplish the mission as
part of a team instead in the aftermath
I made it all about me and the defense
of my ego again when you come into the
office and you say this wasn't my fault
I was doing the right thing everyone
that's looking at you is thinking he's
he doesn't even see what he did wrong
and that's where you know you talk about
in this book you talk about the fact
that one of the most one of the most
horrible things on the battlefield is an
arrogant young person that thinks their
that's not gonna listen anyone and you
when you sit there and put up your
defenses
you're showing everyone that back to the
book yes senior chief Kerry hated me we
love each other but the truth he was a
damn good operator in a firefight I
would have wanted him there as a
tactical leader in his own abrasive way
he'd attempted to mentor me if I had put
down my pride I would have seen it and I
would have learned a lot from him
that never happened I failed to manage
our relationship and it poisoned the
entire platoon it also hurt my
reputation with my teammates myself
deceit finally collapsed Kerry had not
done this to me I'd done this all to
myself I was being punished less for the
decision I'd made and more for the way
I'd fiercely refused to take
responsibility for it
the more I railed against those aligned
against me the more I deserve to be
punished
I wasn't betrayed by my teammates I
betrayed them with my selfishness it was
time to grow up
damn yeah it was exciting because it
suddenly Ranger school suddenly became a
new opportunity and really I set my
sights on you know kind of interestingly
enough I think all of us are super goal
driven people and for the first time I
saw an opportunity and and set a goal
you know it's just what I think all of
us do so well that you know we have a
target to move to and now I have a path
to go after it and that that path became
I want to graduate the honor man in this
course and set it set there you know
woke up the next morning firing up the
guys around me and hey man we're getting
ready to start up again it's gonna be
awesome let's go do this so yeah again
I'm harping on this a little bit but
just the fact that this book is so
powerful because to walk through that
transition I'll tell you anybody that's
read extreme ownership or anyone that
listens to this podcast is going to be
especially there they're gonna be having
even deeper understanding because they I
talk about this all the time and to see
you go down that path
see where it leads and then be able to
come back how be and I'll come back out
as awesome but but it's so powerful to
actually hear from your perspective from
someone that was in that exact position
and doing those things to hear you
saying it and be able to witness the
turnaround it's uh it's powerful
powerful stuff next morning I hit the
ground running and never looked back the
company I joined was full of strangers
no matter I did everything full-bore
made sure I helped but made sure I
helped everyone in my squad whenever I
could I was going to be but this I was
not going to be the disconnected selfish
jerk I had been this go-around
Court was fully invested and you kick
ass and Ranger School
you're not honor man because you find
out that yeah I only find out at the
very end that if you're rolled back
you're not eligible yeah
well I did really well I was ranked at
the top of my pure evals I mean all the
instructors gave me a hey man you're
you're just crushing it and so no matter
it was a goal you know that another
great guy earned it and well-deserved
you end up back at the back of the teams
you go back into a task unit and you're
an assistant platoon commander now is
yeah again is this a reroll as a is it
re reef reload as an assistant platoon
commander oh you're still just super
junior because you were receiving an
animal that no I had just made JG at
this point so back then we still you
know now they're kind of doing it
differently a lot of us seaman Admiral
guys did have the ability to do two
pumps yeah they made me do two boats
yeah yeah they wanted me to do two pumps
and this is I mean for those who are not
aware there was a little bit of impetus
on me because they basically so as
officers if you ever get a letter of
reprimand on your record it effectively
ends your career I mean if it that
official letter goes into your record
you're done you'll never you won't make
the next rank you're going to be out and
they basically wrote this letter my
outgoing CEO who was in Afghanistan
to my incoming CEO who was taken over
the team and they basically said you
made some mistakes and we questioned
your tactical decision making and
leadership abilities but we're gonna
give you a second chance
so this letter and I was you know I was
in the office with the CEO and he put it
into his safe and basically said this
will be burned or shredded at the end of
the deployment if you show us you have
the ability and if you don't it will go
into your pur and they had my officer
record right there and they were like it
will go right here into your record so
and I think they knew the power of that
also and it gave me additional momentum
and I think this is important in
leadership you know in the same way we
raise our kids
the accountability you can't just tell
somebody hey this is what I want you to
go out and do we have to let it lay out
the right and left limits and tell them
this is where you're gonna go and you
have to have those things that hold you
accountable so I don't know if I
necessarily needed that I was pre fired
up on on wanting to get back and set the
example and redeem myself but I will say
on the back of my mind I knew a man you
you got a you got a crush yeah that's a
that's a I don't know if that's happens
in all the military but in the SEAL
Teams there's there's a lot of letters
that get shredded and part of it is like
a cover-your-ass like when I was a
commander a part of its cover your ass
because hey look you screwed up and if
you screw up again and everyone knows
that this has happened multiple times
and you haven't been counseled about it
I look like an idiot and not only do I
look like an idiot
I am an idiot if I'm not documenting
that you screwed something up so I'm
gonna document this and make sure that
you know I've got it documented but by
the way I'm not trying to kill your
career if you can turn around and you
can get back on the path cool this
thing's going in the shredder but here
it is got it you got some ways to go
before this thing goes in that shredder
yep it's a it's pretty common thing in
the SEAL Teams not too common but um so
you're in a task unit you're a system
platoon commander and things are going
good and you you were a lot more
self-aware and again but you have to
read the whole book to get all these
details about that transition you were a
lot more self-aware and you started off
as mobility commander and then
eventually you start working with the
assault team and here we go back to the
book after that first successful mission
now on the assault team I had earned a
spot in the mix and harmonized with the
task units battle rhythm our platoons
rotated back and forth between running
mobility or running the assault force
the pace was intense and the mission
started to blend together in a groundhog
day sword away I may have lost my way
years ago but through God and a
willingness to work hard and learn my
strengths and weaknesses I had earned my
way back into the Brotherhood
and you detail some some good missions
some pretty hot missions you know you
guys gotten some pretty good gunfights
and you're getting towards the end of
deployment and your tu commander he's he
you have a little conversation with him
and he says we're gonna have you run his
Ground Force commander on the next one
for a second what this really meant
failed to register really JP and the
date at this point in the book JP is a
guy he's you're tasking a commander JP
nodded yeah I spoke to Erik and Paul and
we all agree you're ready for it besides
this will help get you up to speed to be
a platoon commander at length I finally
answered that's awesome thanks for the
opportunity you earned it bro he turned
to leave I had done it my career is back
on track at last I knew some in our
community would always hate me for my
mistakes but I had earned back the trust
of the men I served and fought with
since 2004 I've been an officer within
our community rank does not
automatically make you a leader your
character makes you a leader your
actions make you a leader rank is almost
irrelevant
after years of selfish focus on myself
I'd finally understood what it meant to
lean men lead men of this caliber and
what was required of a man in order to
be part of this most elite of all
fraternities the letter in the safe
would be destroyed for an instant the
horizon ahead held no boundaries and
again I skipped this was not like an
easy process man you worked your way
right back up you started with small
jobs you made some mistakes that you you
know that you you talked about the you
lay you lased
it's a Marine colonel and and he was not
happy yeah not happy so quick story
you're doing deconfliction and you can't
identify and so you escalate the
deconfliction to a visible laser and
then you know they realized that that
both sides were friendlies and it was a
Marine Corps colonel that you were
lazing and he wasn't too happy about
that and when you when when your
commander brought you in and said hey
what the hell happened you took
ownership of it and said hey here's the
mistakes I made instead of blaming
everyone
so big big turning point and and I think
this important point you know you you
know I mean within our community it's
pretty hard to turn around when you've
made a major mistake like that I mean no
I'm you guys get out we've had guys that
have been sent to the fleet as some
never come back and then some come back
and redeem themselves but in a gang and
some just get put into ostracized
position of low importance inside the
SEAL Teams right and it's like oh cool
yep we you're stationed over there yep
we know what you're doing and we know
all about you and and we get that you
still have your Trident and you're still
considered a seal but you're not a team
guy and we all know that yeah
you would not be invited to go back to
an operational reveal it you know you're
relegated to training and all that you
know other things so I mean it really is
for people to understand I mean our
community is driven by amazingly
talented warriors and at the end of the
day you know the leader they rely on the
guys next to them and their leaders to
make those good decisions so if you made
bad decisions I mean to be able to come
back and them say okay you know you've
shown us that we can trust you once
again to lead and make the right
decision so it really I tell people
there's a hardest road I've ever walked
I mean when I got wounded I was like I
got this yeah the the trust when broken
is extremely hard to rebuild and I get
asked a lot how do you build trust with
people either whether it's been broken
or whether you don't know them it and
it's very clear in the book and again
this is why people should get the book
the way that you're tasking the
commander and I'm trying to think of the
alias because I know him too JP the way
that you're tasking the commander is
very common to what a guy does he gives
you a little bit of responsibility and
lets you let you earn a little bit of
trust and then once you've heard a
little bit of trust it gives you a
little bit more responsibility
once you've earned a little bit more
trust and that continued going this is
this is now a six-month deployment plus
a year-long workup or whatever so he's
been giving you a little bit of trust
and you've been earning an urn
and earning and earning back your trust
and you are digging out of a deficit
right that's a lot harder so that is a
lot harder when if you show up as a new
guy you're like a zero right cuz P and
then you're gonna get a little trust and
maybe you get to a point too and then
you get a little bit more responsibility
and you get to a point for you were at
like a negative nine and so you had to
just you don't earn your way back to get
to zero and then once you're at zero
then you had to build up and at this
point in the book and you did some again
I'm sorry I'm not gonna go into
everything but you know you had a pretty
dynamic potentially horrible situation
unfolding big gunfight going on some
head counts not accounted for people and
you took charge the situation and that
probably is what you know jumped you up
a bunch of levels in people going okay
you know what we can trust this guy and
and and then you continued these to
build that trust and up to the point
where and I need to explain this because
I didn't up to the point where the task
you to commander said okay one of these
necks coming missions we're gonna make
you the Ground Force commander and what
that means for civilians is that means
you're in charge of everything you're
gonna go out you're gonna be the this
the the main leader the senior leader
not even the main they're gonna be the
senior leader the guy in charge of
everything that's happening on the
battlefield that's that what the Ground
Force commander is and you're now being
it's the end of deployment you're being
told look you've any we want you to be
the Ground Force commander on one of
these upcoming operations and that is
the ultimate trust for someone to give
to a subordinate is hey I want you to go
out and take my job that I would
normally do you go do it so pretty
amazing comeback humbling I mean yeah so
you're almost at the end of deployment
and up like an OP comes up we were one
week away yep 101 we won't hack enough
to get ready to go home
note to self those last operations be
careful first and last man the first
mission
once get you you and it's the mission
comes down it's one of those missions
where you guys are kind of like this
probably isn't gonna go down it's
sketchy Intel high visibility if it goes
and you're thinking because we get a lot
of those you know this is gonna happen
and you get used to getting all amped up
and then eventually you don't even get
amped up anymore you continue with your
daily routine go to the gym work out
whatever in this particular case you
guys you you literally went to the gym
you're working out like normal and I
didn't think there was a chance in hell
this mission was gonna happen and some
of the guys were looking at it but I
just didn't think it was gonna happen it
was already late so we were outside
really the window you know to really try
to execute in a in a good manner in my
opinion and then there were external
things you know there's some classified
factors to it that I don't talk about in
the book were which were other some of
the really big reasons why I did not
think there was any chance this was
gonna happen but but it does and you
guys roll out on a you know al Qaeda
target and definitely you guys had the
Intel that bad guys expected security
team expect enemy security team expected
and and again like we would hear that a
lot I mean it's not like it's not like
oh this Intel's a hundred percent and
you're not gonna do anything different
they tell you there's a security of
enemies security team you're like okay
Chuck
we've heard that 27 times they've only
been there however many times and so
you're always expected that they had
there was a little more detailed
information about this security detail
that made it a little bit hairier than
some of our regular missions I mean
there were things that we knew you I
can't get any yeah I can't get into the
details I'm basically more solid into
absolutely so it made it a little bit
different and kind of raised our hackles
a little more than normal but you know
the process of the mission is the same I
mean I know probably you I've talked to
other people you know the guys did the
bin Laden raid the mechanics of that
mission were the same it was just a
level there
know how we take down a target is pretty
much the same regardless of where you go
and it was the same for this case there
were just some things that yes go mmm
maybe we should prepare a little more
you guys roll on the target and things
get pretty pretty intense pretty quick
once you've once you've you hit the
target you've got it secured now we got
some squirters meaning some folks that
we think have run away from the target
building again I'm not gonna go into the
full detail of the mission which you did
a beautiful job of explaining what this
was like in the book and that's why
people's get the books they can read it
but as we mentioned earlier this ends up
in a firefight and you're in it going
back to the book I keep my radio and
called JP troops in contact troops in
contact I have three wounded including
me the machine guns were still blazing
away at us and they walked their barrels
right and left criss-crossing our
positions with hundreds of 7.62
millimeter bullets I recognized that if
I didn't get a tourniquet on what I
thought was the stump of my left arm I
was going to bleed out I looked back at
Al and the rest of my team behind the
tire right then Al saw me get to my feet
and try and run to join them al told me
this later but I have no recollection
recollection of standing up after I was
hit the first time the PKM gunner
spotted me moving and laid on his
trigger according to Al had only taken a
step or two in my head whipsawed forward
and my body spun around to the left I
fell limp to the ground the team thought
I had been killed I'll recognize the
dire situation we were in and called in
an immediate fire mission the ac-130
crew turned it down the first time two
times before finally making Alek
knowledge that if anything happened to
us it was Al's fault not the gunships
the first 25 millimeter shells hit the
thicket behind the enemy only less than
50 feet from the enemy machine-gun that
engaged me I drifted in and out of
consciousness the entire time awake in a
fog of confusion one minute out cold the
next al risked his life to save me
during a lull and fire he rose from
behind the tire and charged over to me
Shaun lay down cover
as al ran into the teeth of that PKM
bullets cracked and wind around him but
he reached me and dragged me back behind
the tire where he put a tourniquet on my
mangled arm I remember nothing of this
and I didn't know al had even moved me
to the tire until months after the
firefight the medevac bird arrived a few
minutes later and the guys helped us
aboard once we were airborne and out of
harm's way the remainder of the task
unit fell back to the original target
compound to wait for extract but the
fight wasn't over the gunshot gun ship
detected more movement in the thicket
enough was enough al called in 105
millimeter howitzer from the ac-130 and
turned the thicket into a smoking crater
months later when JP visited me at home
I learned that the al Qaeda commander
had fled the house when he heard our
birds coming at the start of the mission
he left part of his personal security
detail behind to fight a battle he had
no stomach for himself
and they died to the last man after
inflicting three casualties on us months
later another SEAL team ran the al Qaeda
commander to the ground and killed him
justice served
so that firefight and again people
should should read the book to get the
details of that firefight but just
reading about you wounded which I've
covered that part and now you're up and
running and get shot in that face and
down every guy's think you're dead and
and you know I should have covered this
with a little bit more detail but you
know you're trying to make calls you're
trying to let people know what's going
on you're trying to decipher the
situation because it was a rough
situation that you guys were in and you
end up you know getting extracted your
boys took care of you they did I owe my
life to those guys I mean they fought
back that gun ship overhead you know for
special operations squadron I owe my
life to those guys that was the closest
fire mission ever in the Iraq war we
were well well they wouldn't bring in
that mission because we were we were
literally within any Danger Close
parameter there were the machine guns
that had me pinned down we're about 45
feet 50 feet away so al did an amazing
job I mean this was his third combat
deployment you know experience JTAC
experience team leader and you know
really I mean he hung it all out there
exposed himself to get me save my life
with my tourniquet and the rest of the
guys you know fought amazingly to get us
out of there and get off the axe and
survive and yeah I wanted out to get a
Navy Cross they downgraded it to a
Silver Star to this day you know I'll
tell anyone he deserved Navy Cross but
all those guys did an amazing job I owe
my life my life to them and the gun ship
it and obviously you know in the
beginning of the book you know the
thought that I'd lost my arm and what
tent what happened is actually I guess
my arm was pinned under me so when I
reached
I couldn't feel it and you know it just
stunned all my nerves there was a nerve
damage too right yeah yeah yeah so when
when and this is kind of an interesting
point that I talked to people about and
something I'm speaking on all the time
now this idea of surviving so having
trained in a career where we learn how
to execute ruthless and devastating
violence of action in an ambush to crush
the enemy and destroy the enemy in that
kill zone on the X and to now be on the
flip side of that coin and be in a very
well executed ambush I mean they had us
it was an L am bullish they had us
caught a very good crossfire you know
and just sheer will for us to fight and
and at least and push back enough that
it gave us a window and and by the end
sheer we were she locked that there
happened to be that tractor tire back
there at least one point of cover
because beyond that there was nothing
but thousands of yards of open Iraqi
desert but to be in that ambush in that
devastating and withering crossfire I
stepped out of that ambush into another
ambush and the next ambush was what I
call a life ambush suddenly here I was I
had been on this amazing journey of
failure growth understanding gaining
experience and wisdom and redemption and
you know career back on track getting
ready to screen and go over to the next
level SEAL team was my goal when I came
back from that deployment I was doing
that and suddenly to find myself laying
in a hospital bed so weak I needed
nurses to help me go to the bathroom
from the amount of blood loss I had the
very first thing I woke to was the
doctors telling me most likely they were
gonna have to amputate my arm I had no
use of my hand I had not seen myself in
the mirror my face was totally blown
apart I had lost my nose cheekbone my
eye my baton the bullet traveled the
bullet hit me right in front of the ear
travelled through my face and exited the
right side of my nose so it took off
most of my nose and took out most of my
cheekbone it vaporized my orbital floor
so my eye actually dropped down into the
new fountain pool in my face so it
damaged my eye muscles I broke all the
bones above my eye had shattered my jaw
broke my jaw to my chin so I have not
seen myself laying in the hospital bed
and I'll be honest I was I wasn't ready
to look at myself I knew I had tubes
coming out of everywhere I was tricked I
was wired shot out of stomach tube
that's how they were feeding me so I
stepped into this next ambush I was you
know with this thought of where do I go
from here and I'll be honest for the
first couple of days I kind of struggled
and I think this is natural so we talked
about this idea of being pinned down on
the X and how we have to survive in
whether it's a real world ambush or it's
a life ambush for anyone that's out
there that's encountered some sort of
devastating event and I classify life
ambush as an event that'll forever leave
physical mental or emotional scars on
you you have to get off the X so I'm
laying there in this hospital bed and
I'm like kicking myself oh my god man
what if I had you do the things that
humans do when bad things happen we
start to think well what if I had done
this or what if I had done that or you
know what if I could go back and change
this fact and I did that for probably I
don't know 36 hours after I got to
pathetic you know just kind of lost in
my mind thinking about it and at one
point I just said stop you can't go back
and change the past man what happens
happen the only thing you can do is
shape the future and I thought back to
that journey that I had been on from
ground zero
from that broken man in Afghanistan
ready to kill myself to where I had come
and I said dude the only thing you can
do from here is shape the future so get
off the ax and go and I I never looked
back from that
point and I tell people that you know
you have to push yourself into those
zones of discomfort so that you can
handle these hard situations when they
come because if you've never Ford
yourself if you've never been put into
these areas of discomfort
you're gonna be crushed when they come
because you're not going to be ready I
was so ready for that moment when it
came I mean you know it took me about 36
hours after I got home to figure it out
but still that's pretty quick for a
devastating injury like that and I never
looked back you're you're in Bethesda
and just just to kind of give a little
bit of detail around that you got some
doctor named female doctor named dr.
Maillard and here we go back to the book
kind of list she's about to list your
kind of your situation that you're in
with energetic bluntness she laid out
the extent of my wounds the machine gun
bullet entered just in front of my right
ear it shattered my job vaporized my
right orbital floor destroyed my cheek
and exited through my nose I'd suffered
nerve damage as well virtually nothing
was left in my cheekbone or ocular floor
bones on the right side of my face she
and her team was amazed I didn't suffer
greater eye damage so that was a
blessing my nose was almost completely
destroyed and we need a full
reconstruction they would need to repair
my shattered jaw implant a titanium
plate to replace the ocular floor and
would have to repair the damage to the
rest of my facial bones on the right
side I was still under the impression
they could fix me right up and get me
back into the team's not not now I was
not so sure and you at this point your
jaws wired shut in your trach so you
can't talk to you right out a note how
many weeks are we looking at here doc
weeks she said surprised no Jay we're
talking years a few years at least years
it didn't even sink in at first there
would be progressive surgeries each one
will need to be fully healed before we
can move on to the next one she went on
to explain that there was no road map
for the extent of the net because of the
extent and nature of my wounds my case
was highly complex and I would recall
require extensive bone and skin grafts
in the years ahead
after she left I struggled to keep my
spirits up this was news I did not want
to hear yeah you know and this is an
interesting fact you know I talked to a
lot of other team guys about this I
think a lot of us we do a really good
job in the SEAL Teams and you know I'd
like to assume other military units do
the same we do a really good job of
preparing guys if they get killed you
know page 2 we make sure they're all
taken care of I don't think any of us
ever give much thought I sure didn't if
I was severely wounded I think most of
us think one side of the coin is you
know it'll be merely a merely a flesh
wound if you know and we'll walk away
and we'll get back and then the other
side of the coin is I'll be killed and I
was good with either of those I you know
just kind of resigned myself to that
back so it was a whole other thing
to be severely wounded and be faced with
this fact that hey you may be forever
disabled and it was tough for you and
here's you run into this situation going
back to the book one afternoon two
family members came to visit us Erika
took the opportunity to step out and
grab some lunch for herself I talked
with them for a bit which left which
quickly fatigued me I started to drift
off before I even realized it while I
was dozing I heard them whispering to
each other I only got fragments of the
conversation but it was enough they were
full of pity for me when Erika returned
and my relatives departed I wrote down
all that had happened recounting it sent
me into a fury again I tore off the
sheet of paper and handed it to her then
I thought for a minute and added never
again never again would someone seal
feel sorry for me I fought for my
country and I'll fight to regain my
health so I will ultimately be able to
return to our nation's battlefields I
was not here for sympathy I was here to
recover to be a leader to set an example
of mental fortitude it would be all too
easy to give up into despair but I
refused there were men and women in this
complex who were far more badly
then I was missing limbs burned
suffering brain trauma or eyesight loss
I would be grateful for what I had
determined to succeed in the days ahead
and when he used these principles I
learned over the last two years to guide
me forward I wrote a note to all my
visitors in a hasp an Erica to hang it
up on the door and here's what the note
said attention to all who enter here if
you are coming into this room with
sorrow or to feel sorry for my wounds go
elsewhere the wounds I received I gotten
a job I loved doing it for people I
loved
supporting the freedom of a country I
deeply love I am incredibly tough and
will make a full recovery
what is full that is the absolute utmost
physically my body has the ability to
recover then I will push that about 20
percent further through sheer mental
tenacity this room you are about to
enter is a room of fun optimism and
intense rapid regrowth if you are not
prepared for that go elsewhere from the
management and awesome.i meaning that
that picture got sent to me by someone
and eventually it got sent to everyone
by everyone so is a viral picture of
that sign on your door that you
eventually put in bigger writing to make
sure everyone saw it that's right
you you eventually you do get home and
and again you know what always I went
Jacko I want to make a really important
point about this cuz that that that was
really a learning point for me or it was
a jump point and and it comes back to
what we talked about earlier in the
beginning a little bit of this social
leadership idea who you surround
yourself with and in that moment I had
individuals that wanted to express pity
and I realized how dangerous that was
because if I listened too long to people
express that it would be easy to accept
that
except this victim mentality and I've
walked that road before and I was like
no way am I going to allow that to
happen it is a choice and that's what
people need to understand you know
having a positive attitude on how you
handle the situation's you're in is a
choice and the more you accept
positivity and drive it forward the more
you actually start to believe it and it
will create momentum and that's really
what happened with that sign I said it I
will not allow that to happen again no
one will come in here and be sad because
I refuse I will not allow it and and you
you never know the impact of the
decision that you're gonna make you
never know how even though deep down
inside you're like you know holy shit
how do I get out of this situation but
you project that positivity who you can
bring with you and bring up and how much
you can leave a an impact on the last a
lifetime that sign has gone on to help
hundreds of thousands of people I've had
people write me that have had cancer
I've had people that have read that have
written me that have had major horrific
accidents I didn't keep the sign I had
it framed and it hangs in the wounded
ward at Walter Reed and the bottom of
the sign is like rub clean now and I'm
told that all these wounded warriors
whenever they go to a surgery they go by
and they rub it and it just it continues
to have this impact secretary Gates
wrote about the sign in his book
Michelle Obama's book just came out she
wrote about the sign and what the impact
is so one moment of saying I'm not going
to allow someone else to drive my
thinking makes all the difference
and I tell so many people that it is a
choice it is a choice you can choose to
be a victim and feel sorry for yourself
or you can choose to be a vector and
drive forward even if you don't believe
it in the moment it doesn't matter you
know say it live it and start driving
forward and that belief will catch fire
within you and everybody else surrounds
you no doubt about it man and and the
the unfortunate opposite that is when
you start allowing yourself to be
negative and you start listening to
people that want to be negative and be
and drag you down you can easily add
yourself in that direction as well so
when you make a choice and make a
decision on which one of those two
directions you want to move in up or
down we recommend you move up move
forward yeah absolutely
later that spring Erik and I went out to
eat at a local Outback Steakhouse to
celebrate the unwire Alaia it been
almost seven months since I've been able
to chew food I was still underweight and
confined to a wheelchair because of the
grass but we both needed a night out I
just you know I when I was reading this
book I was like eating something
whatever you know and it's just one of
those things that we all take for
granted every single day and you know
faddle I've had multiple prisoners of
war on this podcast and you know they're
eating a ball rice once a day or ball of
rice twice a day that has chips of wood
in it for three years for six years and
here here you are you know you're not
the prisoner of war but something as
simple as eating a steak and that really
like hit me hard because as you know I
takes takes very seriously and and to
think that like for seven months no
steak and the daily things and and and
that always gets me thinking about the
daily things that when I talk to my
friends that have been wounded
it's like it's the daily everyday things
and as a matter of fact when we had Jim
Webb on and he was talking about one of
his friends that have been wounded in
Vietnam and he's like that's the daily
Kurds like that guy was courageous in
Vietnam but he's courageous every single
day takes him X amount of time to get up
out of bed take some X amount of time to
get his prosthetic so take some X amount
of time to do normal functions that
people can normally do easily he's got a
struggle with them all and he does it
every single day without complaining
daily courage and so just thinking about
you in that situation man
awesome I flew to Chicago almost once a
month the preparation for my first
surgery with dr. Walton which he'd
scheduled for July the airports and
their crowds continued to be a torment
little kids pointed at me and called to
their mothers to look at me two people
refused to talk to me they'd act ashamed
or embarrassed or they'd set expressions
of pity on their faces internally I
raged at them are these the people I
sacrificed for coming back from a ship
coming back from Chicago on one trip I
just broke every one who stared at me I
treated with a sudden boo by the end of
the trip though I realized I need to do
something different or the bitterness
would eat me alive it gave me a thought
I came up with an idea I went online and
designed a couple t-shirts the first one
said stop staring I got shot by a
machine gun it would have killed you I
put an American flag on the back and
called it wounded where so are you still
making wounded wear shirts so weird
wears on pause for right now but it will
be coming back okay we've got some work
we're getting things online in 2019 but
yeah a lot of people have asked me when
will it come back it will be back I
assure you yeah so this podcast is
eternal so most likely when people are
listening to this it is live you can get
it you can get your wounded wear t-shirt
that's right yeah
you were talking about that that sign
and that sign got so much attention and
it was so so impactful to so many people
you ended up going to the Oval Office
you ended up meeting President Bush with
your family and then you ended up coming
back to the White House again and we're
going back to the book I went to Mike
mom sores Medal of Honor ceremony in the
White House that April Michael is a
fellow seal who had jumped on a hand
grenade thrown onto a rooftop he had and
saved two of his teammates in a
firefight in Ramadi he shielded his
brothers with his own body and paid the
ultimate price for that
it was deeply moving to be there to see
Mike's family receive his posthumous
Medal of Honor but while I was there I
met another seal named Ryan joke
he'd been part of the team three and had
served with legendary
sniper Chris Kyle in Iraq during the
2006 campaign Ryan had been a mark 48
machine gunner for the team and during a
firefight that spring a bullet had
struck his weapon then hit him in the
face destroying his right eye he
survived and reached Bethesda much as I
would a year later but nerve damage cost
him his vision in his left eye the
prospect of spending the rest of his
life blind had to have been terrifying
though he never showed it
instead he announced that if he had to
be blind he would be the best damn blind
man there was so that's where I met you
for the first time obviously uh Mikey
and Ryan and Chris were all with me in
task unit bruiser and you came out for
the for the Medal of Honor ceremony for
Mikey and I actually remember looking at
you guys you know looking at you guys
talking to each other and I actually
thought I had pictures of it but I
didn't I thought I had pictures of you
two talking but I didn't have any
pictures but it was it was crazy to sit
there and look at both you guys that
have been you know both been shot
unfortunately Ryan you know he lost
vision in both eyes which obviously
could have happened to you very easily
and thank God you know it didn't and you
guys kind of you know I guess when you
have getting shot in the head and calm
and you guys kind of became Bros and
continue on here Ryan and I bumped into
each other on multiple occasions over
the next several months on one of the
occasions Ryan had come out to the East
Coast SEAL Teams for a wounded warrior
benevolent organization conference as we
made small talk and met different people
I Ryan and another SEAL who had been
shot me I were joking around and came up
with the idea for a club for seals who
had been shot in the head
it was a very small club we decided to
call the club shit
seals hit in the head we unanimously
voted on our motto this club sucks so
yeah just just pretty awesome and that's
pretty much the you know that's
definitely Ryan Biggles jobs attitude
was he was just gonna have an awesome
time all the time regardless what
situation he was in he was gonna he was
gonna get after it and yeah what's cool
to see you guys meet yeah Ryan was
awesome and you know he was ahead it was
interesting because the reconstruction
process that they were doing with me was
the same they were doing with Ryan and
obviously I was blessed to keep my
vision although they were fixing things
with this right eye but so often I'd
call him and I'd be like hey you know
you had this done how'd it go you know
what did you do do you have any
recommendations like anything you know
you go to the people who have experience
so Ryan and I got close through that
yeah I'm just kind of learning from him
well one of the this this was another
bit of a of a surprise to me well again
this is the kind of thing that I never
had to think about but here you go going
back to book and the months that follow
it I knew that I was in for the long
game the slog through surgeries and
setbacks continued and again you got to
read this book to realize the absolute
just medical a medical trauma that
you're going through day-in day-out
and this really drove at home to me I
call it a medical budge there you go
it's really what medical buds and here's
here's one thing that just hit me like a
ton of bricks by the summer of 2009 I
was starting to run low on the available
patches of skin for grafting my body was
roped with scars from surgical sites and
over a dozen grafts that to me I'm
thinking myself I mean you're running
out of skin to graft to to do damp to do
damage repair to your face what is that
process like
so a lot of times they harvest the skin
from you know your thighs and areas and
and it and it wasn't that I was just
running out of skin they were running
out of skin because I've got quite a few
tattoos so my back is totally tattooed
you know you know top my arms so that's
what the problem was becoming putting
tattooed skin on other parts of your
bodies no big deal they could have cut
that in a second but obviously they were
like you know we did I did not want to
put tattooed skin on my face so that's
where we were starting to run into
issues and this really is something that
a lot of people don't understand with
with battlefield injuries is they're
super dirty bombs are dirty bullets are
dirty and you fall in the soil and you
bleed into the soil overseas and that's
dirty
so the vast majority of wounded warriors
come home especially from this war with
infection problems and there's so many
guys myself included that it's not your
initial injuries that are as devastating
I mean obviously there's levels of
devastation but for so many of us it's
the infection problems so many guys come
back with their limbs and end up losing
their limbs because of the infection I
had major infection problems which
caused us to continue have to do more
and more grafts they would have to cut
out what they had done because it was
infected and failed they rebuilt my nose
three times so the first two that
totally cut out and start over so that's
why we were starting to run into issues
hey where do we you know where do we get
more cartilage where do we get more skin
they can use cadaver but it does not it
does not last it doesn't always take so
they always want to use your own body
and that's where we started to run into
issues
September 24 2009
Ryan Jobe is dead I hadn't known Ryan
incredibly well I wouldn't call him a
close friend we talked on the phone
occasionally we shared a common
experience and discussed our notes on
recovery and we shared a twisted sense
of humor but above all I respected his
spirit and relentless energy recapture
all he could out of life he made the
most of every moment and achieved things
most people with their eyesight intact
never would in 2008 he climbed Mount
Rainier when I heard about that I was
blown away in the climbing community the
14,000 foot volcanic Mountain in
Washington state is considered one of
the most difficult to summit in all
North America it has deadly crevasses
narrow ledges and glacial ice it is as
technical climb as you can find Mount
Ranier claims on average three lives a
year of those who aspire to summit and
Ryan made it to the top two years after
that bullit robbed him of his vision he
and Kelly who he had married he and
Kelly were getting ready to have a
daughter together Ryan had started a new
life found a fresh path to blaze and had
built something from the ruins
he really was being the best damn blind
man out there then with the snap of
cosmic fingers it was all stolen from
him and if you don't know the story
there was he went through one of his
many surgeries because he was still
going through surgeries and after the
surgeries there was complications and he
he died as well they killed him I mean
they messed up yeah there was Harris
overdosed him that was a total mistake
and
that slayed me Ryan's death rocked me
because I know how hard it is to stay
positive and to drive forward despite
these really hard injuries and it just
it killed me to know that you know it
was a medical mistake that killed him
you know I mean it's hard enough to go
through all this and you survive battle
and you know all these things so that
that that really shook me when Ryan had
died and you're still looking at unknown
numbers of surgeries ahead and at the
time yeah that was halfway through so
this was 2009 I ended up having
surgeries all the way up until 2011 yeah
and the other thing that was crazy about
Ryan was I'm not gonna say he was out of
the woods I mean but he was pretty damn
far out of the woods and that's why you
know to lose him like that was just a
fucking nightmare yeah
you at this point you still want to get
back to the teams and you're trying to
get your arm fixed to the point where
you can have enough mobility in it to to
change magazines to operate your weapon
so you're going to a bunch of different
people trying to see who is who can make
this happen
you finally find a guy that's you know
you think you have a good lead on
somebody that can make this happen and
you go to see him and he says going back
to the book Jay I'm gonna be frank with
you if you were my son I wouldn't let
you do this what you have now is the
best possible outcome if you proceed and
have another surgery you'll probably
lose some of the range of motion you
have now worse you'll set yourself up
for a lifetime of chronic pain the drive
home was a quiet one for me as I
deliberated whether or not to roll the
dice one last time
by the time I turned off the freeway and
for Virginia Beach I knew it was not
worth the risk my days as an operator
were over part of me always suspected
this might happened this might happen
now it was confirmed
I had no epiphanies during the drive
home about what to do now as the that
dream to kick doors again slipped away
what would I do how would I support my
family I didn't have any answers but I
knew one thing I'd live as Ryan Joe Pat
honor his memory
and never take another day for granted
Ryan's death reminded me that nothing is
guaranteed in life they can be taken
away in a heartbeat the life you've
built with everything you've got
can come apart an instant from
circumstances far beyond your control
you either adapt and overcome or you
become a casualty of those twists of
fate I refused to be a casualty so you
get this news that hey you're not either
we can't do this this is what you got
what you got this is where you're at and
the idea of getting back operational
again is gone and it's funny Hyun I were
just talking about you know you were
over talking to some students at Budds
and you had a guy that was was but what
he been injured older guy you said it
wasn't real to come back yeah he's
medically dropped medically dropped not
going to be able to come back and so
dream is gone it's interesting you're
talking to him and you'd been through it
you've been through it and your attitude
was okay
what we do now and like I told him I
mean so you know this this idea of life
ambushes I told him I said you just
stepped into one and they're they're
small ones and big ones a lot of times
they're totally unexpected but the
reality is most ambushes aren't totally
unexpected there are indicators that we
see before we ever get into it whether
we're aware of seeing them or not
sometimes it's after the fact that we
look back 9/11 is a good example of
there were indicators that we missed
before 9/11 happened for us as seals
when we move into areas we know that's a
bad area
we are in an area where we're getting
channelized there's high ground above us
this would be a good area to execute an
ambush you know for me I had seen those
indicators coming so I kind of knew what
was coming I had met so many doctors who
said literally the doctor from Johns
Hopkins who put my arm back together
they actually wrote a medical journal
about what he did with my elbow I mean
he successfully reconstructed an elbow
that had been totally destroyed and it
was always funny to me there's an
arrogance and I think there has to be
there has to be a little bit level of
Beranek arrogance and confidence and
high level orthopedic surgeons so every
time I'd go meet one of these guys
they'd be like oh yeah I can fix your
arm and then they slap that x-ray up and
I'd watch it was like the air got sucked
out of the room as they looked at it and
then they would look at me and they'd
say yeah man I'm sorry I they're like I
don't even know how your arms work in
the way it is so when I met the guy from
Duke who was one of the premier you know
hand and arm guys literally the guy that
put my arm together was probably a deep
premier hand and arm gone I tried to get
him to go back and do more and he said
no he said there's no way in hell he
said your arm he said going into your
arm and getting what we got is a miracle
he's like I am NOT going back in and I
recommend against anybody else doing it
well I still tried to find other doctors
and it was this guy from Duke who
finally convinced me so when that moment
came I kind of knew so as opposed to
this young man from Budds it was less
unexpected than what I step you know for
me it was less unexpected so it just
became where do I go from here and and
interestingly enough I had laid out some
different things for myself one I wanted
to do a 20-year career so that kind of
became my first thing can i still stay
in and finish my career maybe I can't be
operational at this point I was at Dam
Neck and I think I was at 18 years at
this point so it'd have been four years
almost four years from my injury and so
over a couple of days I talked to I was
working in operations and I just said
hey what are our options what can we do
and they actually allowed me to go work
some new things different projects and
different things so it was great they
allowed me to finish what I set out to
do but it also gave me a decent amount
of time at this point it was another
year before we started the medical
retirement process which actually took
two years so it carried me to 21 years
and it gave me a lot of time to really
look at you know where does my future go
from here and kind of lay out what are
my new passions what is my purpose and
where do I go from this life after the
military what can I do with all these
lessons that I've learned and you know
how do I pay it forward how do I honor
Ryan how do I honor all these guys that
everyday I walk by this granite wall and
they didn't get a choice they didn't get
a choice to come home so thankfully you
know I had that time it's still within
the community but also coming to grips
with the fact that you know like I
talked to those young men about so many
people are so strongly tied to what they
do for a living that they cannot
function if suddenly it's taken away
from them there's a lot of meat a lot of
police officers and firefighters or
professional athletes that if suddenly
their career is over they don't know how
to function without that they've tied
their identity so much around what
they've done and I realized that the
lessons that I learned in the the SEAL
Teams and this journey that I had been
on was incredibly relatable and it was
and nothing to do with tactical lessons
you know I didn't need to be the guy
that got out and taught you how to shoot
or do anything and that like that what I
realized it realized is there were
amazing life lessons the lessons human
lessons lessons in leadership and
teamwork and overcoming adversity and
this idea of helping people you know not
only survive but thrive from cry
said ambushes so that really started to
become the path that I was walking and
to help other wounded warriors well I
just want to wrap this last little
section of the book because we're
talking about the identity and what you
invested your life into and you say this
I held the Trident in my hand this
golden emblem had driven my life I
focused on it I coveted it I became
enamored by it I almost lost it and then
I earned it back before I sacrificed my
body for it only then did I finally
understand what it truly represented it
carried the spirit of warrior poets like
Mike Murphy Mike Mansoor and Chris Kyle
it carried the spirit of my friends Ryan
job Adam Brown Mike mcgrevey Kevin
Houston and the 79 other men who have
made the ultimate sacrifice for freedom
and the brotherhood since 9/11 I didn't
know why God spared me but I did know I
would find a way into the future where I
would use each and every day to honor my
brothers who had not made it home
and I think obviously you've done a lot
to honor our brothers and I think you
continue to do that obviously every day
with what you're doing and how you're
doing it and how you're taking the
lessons that you learned and bringing
them to to more people spreading the
word broadly what did that translation
transition look like like the you know
from the time you got out into where you
are now because you know I mean
obviously everyone that's in the
military right now one day I hate to
break the news to y'all one day you're
gonna be not in the military anymore
bring us from you know the end of your
career into where you are now and where
you're focused right now and and what
you're doing yeah absolutely I think
that transition is a lot harder than
people realize I think a lot of things
I'm sure you experienced this we take
for granted the level of structure that
exists in the military and suddenly you
get out into the civilian world and
that's not there I was a little bit
fortunate enough that I had launched the
nonprofit wounded where later to become
the combat wounded coalition while I was
still on active duty but so when I got
out that kind of became my focus god I
will say that I made the mistake that a
lot of military members and especially
Special Operations members make when
they get out I tried to do everything
everything I saw was an opportunity that
I didn't want to lose out on and i
falsely can convince myself yeah i had
the ability to do that so running the
nonprofit we did a lot of amazing things
you know two and a half million dollars
we helped thousands of wounded warriors
even created a program specifically to
help wounded warriors build structure
find their new passion but what I
started to realize and I was doing all
this while I was still trying to speak
and develop content and work on
things and take care of a family and
kids and all these things and I kind of
had an epiphany in 2018 I'd been doing
this you know I had retired in 2013 so
five years I'd been doing this and I
suddenly realized you've got to find
that one thing that you truly are going
to make a difference at and I took a
step back in 2018 and said where can I
have the most impact and what really is
my new mission what drives my passion
where is my destination where I'm where
am I going to set that course to go and
I realized I look back you know we were
doing a lot of great things with the
nonprofit but there's 43,000 veteran
nonprofits out there we are losing more
guys to suicide right now then we lost
to the enemy and I said okay so one
option is you go create a whole nother
nonprofit but there's a lot of good ones
out there and I think that's part of the
problem it's diluting some of the
message so I said maybe I'm better off
focusing on helping a whole bunch of
people with this message and lending my
support so to another organization so
myself and the board made the decision
that we were going to face down our
organization in 2018 and 2019 made that
shift that I'm totally focusing on
delivering this content to help people
overcome adversity to to launch
themselves out of failure and to not
only survive which some people just
survived from these life ambushes from
these massive catastrophic events but to
thrive from them to use them as a launch
point to get better and to understand
how to do that and because I realized
man you know this you've written all
this amazing content on it and all that
is coming into the second book that will
come out in December called overcome so
I have online courses that are getting
ready to come on board here in the next
couple of months and I just want to get
out there and help as many people as I
can and then lend myself to some of the
organizations that are out there that
are helping our wounded warriors
specifically with post-traumatic stress
and traumatic brain injuries one of the
things I've started doing a lot of
research and what we're beginning to
understand is I used to think that if we
could help guys find a new purpose after
they got out it would help solve their
problems wounded warriors but what we're
beginning to understand is that we have
never the way we train down the way we
have fought wars is exposing guys
especially in front-line combat units
and special operational operation units
to level of blast that we've never in in
up until this point the way we trained
in the military we haven't done before
so I mean you look at our breachers and
how many blasts we exposed them to just
in training you know and what we're
starting to see I mean I've had multiple
friends now that have killed themselves
who I said no way no way and I've
watched these downward slides and what
we're starting to find out is we are
creating physiological impacts on the
brain from these continued exposures to
these blasts so we need more research we
need you know we need more non
pharmacological solutions to these
problems and there's a lot of things
that are out there that are on the
forefront so one of the things with
research I started doing some stuff with
the concussion Legacy Foundation which
is the same group working with the NFL
or you know highlighting the impact of
CTE on NFL players and we're beginning
to realize that some of our special
operations guys like Rob guzo who took
his life
severe CTE but what they figured out is
it's different some of the premium and
premier neurologists that are out there
figuring out it's different it's it's
blast and the blast goes all the way
through the brain as opposed to a
concussion that creates an impact and
there's a centralized location now for
guys or even gals out there that have
had multiple concussions that creates
more but the bottom line is we need this
research so I donated my brain to the
concussion Legacy Foundation and I'm
encouraging all the veterans that are
out there if you have been in combat
donate your brain
you don't need it I get it you don't
need it when you're gone and they're not
going to come early
and collect you know but the bottom line
is it is an amazing way to be able to
give back to the veterans that are
coming up behind you because they don't
have enough veteran brains in the brain
banks that are out there to understand
the kind of trauma we're putting on our
brains and until they can and obviously
they can't study the brains while we're
still alive
so if if you want a way to get back look
up the concussion Legacy Foundation and
donate your brain I did it we need the
research 20 30 years from now we can
make a difference to save some young
warrior that's out there that got
exposed to blasts and now can't figure
out why his world is falling apart
around him so those are my passions
that's my purpose and I want to help as
many people out there I want to make you
better help you thrive from adversity
help you thrive from failure in crisis
and for our wounded warriors I want to
help try and solve this epidemic we're
seeing in the suicides and the brain
trauma yeah that's I mean that's just
awesome it's awesome see moving forward
with that and I know we've been going
for a while here and that's probably a
pretty good place to wrap where do you
where can people find you where should
people locate you and when they want to
when they want to hear from you yeah
absolutely best place go to Jason Redman
comm that's my website and you can see
what I'm doing you can contact me
through there I'm on all the major
social media platforms
Jason Redman on Facebook and Jason
Redman WW on Instagram and Twitter
awesome
echo speaking of people making people
better you have any quick
recommendations on how you know we could
improve ourselves sure this is actual
Charles by the way I have one question
in Ranger school when they told you to
like alright when they asked you you
need your Gucci was that the thing that
kind of sent you over that when they
said the Gucci think
no I don't think it was that I really it
was it was the land nav comments I mean
I had taught land map so the funny thing
about that Gucci jacket is so the army
guys were only allowed to wear the army
jacket liner well we didn't have those
yeah
and is Gucci Patagonia I had the
remember the green phones that came yeah
that's what I had so every day I put
that on the Ranger instructors would
lose their minds and and in the
beginning I had such a bad attitude that
I just took it in the negative way well
the second time I went through it became
the how often can I put this on and spin
these guys so I I still have it don't
have it every time I pull it out of my
closet it puts a smile on my face you
know it's nice what else no that's it
for questions yeah yeah we can talk
about getting better though yeah and and
Jays about to start training in
jiu-jitsu boom so yeah he's gonna need a
jujitsu key so we need to get that
hooked up where are we gonna hook him up
with a key from origin 100% not even 99
percent 100 percent 100 for g and all
made in America okay okay that's what we
need you know continue to grow this
country yes sir
so yeah origin if you're into jiu-jitsu
getting into jiu-jitsu or already into
this you want a Gihon newgy or another
geek fortune I thought you guys a used
ghee yeah you the market for used gi's
know there's probably depends on who
wore it I guarantee there's people out
there that would love it ja kogi but
that gets a little weird yeah that
doesn't smell good well yeah maybe some
some people maybe if someone like lost
weight or something you know I don't use
this happens to a venue where out of
ghee or I was talking to Pete the other
day the amount of ghee pants orgy's
period that had been returned is like so
he said yeah we get like three g's back
a year where someone's actually worn
somehow they just don't wear out though
we're GZ just do not wear out yeah yeah
get something that yeah you gotta like
um yeah like if you lose weight or
something and then you don't use it
anymore
or if you're like you get the new one
and you know how like you turn you back
to the old one because the new one
that's the new hotness you know you
don't really wear it anymore so you give
it to your friend or something like this
there's that you are these rash guards
t-shirts other stuff yeah supplements
supplements joint warfare joint warfare
and krill oil turned out to be the most
important supplements there are in my
opinion you thought it was the protein
powder and the creatine that's what we
thought in the beginning not anymore
joint joint or 400% ease we thought that
yeah well yes I agree
we do have during warfare coil and if
you do want protein you might as well
enjoy it yes sir
get yourself some milk it's still good
for it you know we need protein we do
you know you need the protein that's why
we have milk which have you tried milk I
haven't okay
we're get you some milk and especially
well it depends what flavors you like I
like mint chocolate chip I am a fan of
it okay so which isn't mint bulk but
apparently doc Luke hates mint well
apparently he was going berserker the
other day saying why would you drink
something that tastes like toothpastes
yeah yeah but so as it turns out some of
the unit to the back to another fence
analogy some it's like you either love
it or you really don't like it that's as
it turns out that'll this situation with
them where we got mint peanut butter
chocolate vanilla gorilla I'm a huge fan
peanut butter chocolate okay yes okay
that's my chocolate I got hostel with my
whole family the other day well not with
my whole family with my wife and my
youngest daughter because there was no I
wanted some yogurt and there was no
blueberry there was no strawberry there
was no coconut there was only vanilla
and so I started saying why would a
human being in 2019 buy vanilla yogurt
like choose use of all the I get if it
comes in the
lady packing you end up with it you know
understood but straight-up selected no
wrong answer you know so I had to get
hostile
super hostile and I was telling my wife
and my youngest daughter that they are
crazy for just like in that vanilla yeah
they are for sure but at the end of the
day we don't fear to understand other
people they have other opinions my my
youngest daughter nine years old she
makes so what she does is she takes
strawberries cuts them up and then she
put the whipped cream on it and then she
takes warrior kid milk strawberry and
sprinkles at a nice yeah yeah well
protein protein pump
yeah yeah it's good oh yeah worry kid
nope that's for the kid right little
more formidable I know that possibly do
drink it yes sir also if you want to
represent while you're on this path
jiu-jitsu working out waking up early
you wake up early I do all right
I get up at 5:00 okay so the up early
crew if you're on that oh and you want
to represent aesthetically chocolate as
a store it's called Jacko's store so go
to jockle store calm that's where you
can get shirts discipline equals freedom
a shirt that has chuckles face on it it
says good backwards it's for you it's a
message for you anyway you want a very
very very fitting for today's story
right yeah of it looking at yourself yes
adversity that's right here got a prank
problem going on good good opportunity
look forward actually I like that like a
free you know cuz there's a lot of
different approaches you know like you
say get off the X and like look forward
absolutely man you have you so many
people look back they look back at what
they've lost
yeah back oh yeah what's going on right
now kind of thing which is natural by
the way oh
right huh but man yeah that's good you
likely back long enough to assess what
you did wrong and then you move forward
yeah
learn some lessons and then move forward
but yeah so yeah if you want to
represent go to jockle store calm a lot
of cool stuff on there if you like
something get something new hoodies up
there by the way by the way are they
thick okay those of us you know that's
not what I'm looking for
you know we're making I'm gonna think
I'm gonna call when I finally get the
hoodies that I want McCall Michigan
hoodies or Minnesota hoodies for them
people mean Eskimo yeah yeah we're all
trade off yup north north pole or there
you go on the vortex yeah you think they
wanted that lightweight hoodie during
the polar vortex bro no but I'm just
saying there's like different regions of
the world so you get that line with fur
guarantee you for 20 below yeah region
that we're talking about is cold yes sir
okay I dig it in that is a good name for
it for sure
cool so anyway yes when it gets cold you
can have hot chocolate tea yes as
opposed to call jock whitey can milk is
on Amazon and will ever subscribe to the
podcast if you want to don't forget
about the warrior kid podcast you know
it's good a lot of people say that's the
best podcast for kids ever yeah there no
law yes from kids and here's why you
feel that way you won't be wrong by the
way that you feel this way because it's
so simple so you're like thinking of it
in terms of well yeah when my kid
listens to this oh they're gonna get it
yeah fully and then you listen to it
you're like I'm kind of getting to me
you know like it's kind of for me so I
love with adults man we complicate yeah
every yeah you do yes
yeah that's the that's why I love the
warrior Kid books this is a message for
a ten-year-old
and guess what I've had I have many
adults that say thank you for writing
your book Echo's one of them another one
yes yeah so does that don't forget that
warrior kid soap from young Aidan 13
year old warrior kid has his own
business he's getting after it
he's got goats up in central California
he milks them
you can't sell goat milk or whatever in
California cuz they got all these rules
so what can you do with it you can make
soap he started making soap and his
motto is stay clean which I paid up
don't worry I gave it to you I'm so
arrogant and egotistical I want to take
the credit for the for the name or
whatever the mantra of of Aden soap
store yeah
messed up that so it's a collaborative
English YouTube channel
Echo's makes a bunch of videos speaking
of arrogant he thinks his videos are
great and he posts them on there I there
you go never demonstrated that but yeah
no rule
thank you okay you sure about that yeah
I think so yes that ships with yes yes
sir yeah YouTube there's a good on the
video version of this podcast too by the
way
sure you know you can see what everybody
looks like if you care about that sort
of thing um people watch people watching
ones with guests because they want to
see what because they know what I look
like they know what echo looks like they
want to see what Jay redwood looks like
I want to see what what does a man look
like that took a round really yeah
they're cool at that point they stopped
the podcast and press play on YouTube
yeah see what's going on it is two
million dollars in sexiness so if you've
ever wondered where your American tax
dollars went it went to a good cause
they're not you're not quite the Six
Million Dollar Man you're the two men
that's your million dollars yeah 100
psychological warfare you can get that
you it'll it is it's a little something
to help you out look it up on iTunes
that's all we're gonna say about it
period well period I have more to say
period you gotta go man Jase gotta go
yeah
what maybe Jay doesn't know what
psychological warfare is guess what it
is it's a it's an album with tracks
chocolate tracks telling you how to get
through moments of weakness that you
might come across and about instilling
that discipline to get up I've actually
listened to psychological
I thought I got flanked for a second but
it actually wasn't I stand corrected
yeah what else we got we got on it if or
when you add to your home gym situation
your home fitness situation going on it
calm / Chuck with a lot of good stuff on
there a jump rope if you don't like it
rings actually rings are a hundred
percent in my opinion I'm signing a
hundred percent the best thing that you
can get I need some rings yeah I know
where to go first I'm thinking about
that for my home gym you know you
definitely definitely gotta have rings
in it that's the first thing you need is
a the first thing you need is a pull-up
bar but you can do more with rings and
you can do poems so you might as well
just get rigs kettle bells tube by the
way oh we got some books okay first of
all book again read a bunch of excerpts
today but not even close to putting
giving justice to this book to tried it
by Jason Redman we will have it up on
the site right yes sir it's on the top
menu menus on the podcaster looks from
episodes at our website and a photo that
looks like a cool website for 1996 yeah
I was the only guy and I was like yeah
well that's 96 but that's cool
maybe echos just doesn't like me retro
eight more years it's gonna look cool
with the website so you know you're
ahead of your time
the Jacko's store website looks all cool
yes it does why is that well you know
very easy okay
cool that sounds great we also got some
ebooks miking the Dragons kids book for
kids between the ages of 4 and 100 yeah
so get Mikey the Dragons way the warrior
kid and marks mission those are out and
we have book 3 which I completed is
being drawn by the artist right now John
Bozak we're gonna put that up so you can
pre-order it so you so I don't sell out
of books like we did Mikey the Dragons
immediately so I will fix that this time
I apologize last time discipline equals
freedom Field Manual get that how to get
after it
audio is on iTunes Amazon music Google
Play extreme ownership
first book that I wrote with my brother
lave babban and the follow-on to that
that I cotta me a leadership I'm talking
about don't go too far in one direction
or the other as a leader or you will
blow it Ashlin fronts my leadership
consultancy and what we do is solve
problems through leadership
whatever problems you have in your
organization i 100% guarantee they are
leadership problems that's what they are
and that's what we do
me Lafe Babb and JP Janelle Dave Burke
Flynn Cochran Mike Cirelli Mike bimah go
to echelon front comm if you need help
with leadership in your team or
organization the muster speaking of
leadership this is our Leadership
Conference 2019 this is when it's going
down May 23rd and 24th in shy pound
mm-hm shy town Senate town Chicago where
you get stakes we're gonna we're gonna
talk about leadership September 19th and
20th in Denver Colorado mmm
we're gonna its takes there are two and
then December 4th and 5th and Sydney
Australia we're gonna go there and yes
we're gonna get stakes there as well
look at all these events have sold out
completely and all these are gonna sell
out too
so if you want to come go to extreme
ownership calm to register I haven't
even put where it's selling a lot right
now and I haven't even posted anything
about it
so I'm scared so I don't want people to
I don't want non podcast listeners to
get a crack at it early yeah and I'm
gonna have to post soon so to let people
know what's up
EF online so this is online interactive
leadership training it is interact no I
know it goes sounds like one of those
words like a like a buzz word right
interactive but you straight up in Iraq
yeah like okay remember those video
games back in the day we're all about
the same age swear on the old school
computers right where you couldn't
you're like oh I'm traveling through the
woods and I can go down this
choose-your-own-adventure yeah you know
and you can choose one and it'll go do
it
it's kind of like that yes you have to
make leadership decisions in the online
Trinity to want to learn the principles
you have to try and apply them to combat
and business situations
so that's EF online comm check it out
you can get it as an individual or you
can get an enterprise version for your
whole company so that's that an EF
overwatch where we're connecting
combat-proven
leaders from the spec ops community and
from the combat aviation community with
companies in the Cillian sector that
need leadership proven leadership to
align and move their company forward go
to EF over watch.com for that and if you
want to continue this conversation ask
questions give us answers tell me what I
mispronounced tell me what historical
fact I got wrong hit us up we're on the
social media on Twitter Instagram and on
the face Facebook
Redmond is at Jason Redmond
ww echo is that echo Charles I'm at
jackal willing echo anything else no
thank you so much for coming
Jay Redmond any closing thoughts to
shout out to everybody out there you
know most importantly obviously my
beautiful wife who our journey is
included in this book so if you are one
of the lovely females that are out there
and that would say maybe this book isn't
for me
it absolutely is once again and it's not
a combat book it is a journey of
leadership and at its heart and soul it
is a love story and my wife never batted
an eye on this journey and this book is
dedicated to her and my kids whose love
brought me home so big shout out to them
and a big shout out to both you guys
thank you for having me on and forget it
out there and we need more leadership
out there and you guys are putting it
out there so it's awesome brother thanks
for coming on and
obviously thanks for your service to our
country thanks for what you did for the
teams and thanks for what you're
continuing to do right now you've
sacrificed a lot and you're still out
there every day grinding and making
things happen thanks for doing that and
man overcome and of course of thanks to
all our military personnel that are
standing watch around the world to
protect our freedoms and utmost
appreciation for those wounded warriors
like Jay who continue to sacrifice
bravely every day for the freedoms that
we all enjoy and also thank you to our
police law enforcement firefighters
paramedics EMTs correctional officers
Border Patrol's all the first responders
out there who stand watch on the home
front to keep us all safe and to
everyone else out there that's listening
there really are no excuses there none
men like Jay Redman proved that men like
Ryan job prove that without question so
don't allow yourself to fall short don't
allow yourself to give anything less
than everything you've got to take the
fight to the enemy whoever and whatever
that enemy might be do what you're
supposed to do be who you're supposed to
be by going out there every day and
getting after it then until next time
this is Jason Redman and Beco and Jocko